Pock!
schnitzel, ne warum? ich hab grad aus irgendwelchen kurzen schnitzel gelesen
schmithi2802 dankeschön für acht monate beim subscript
warum hab ich grad schnitzel gelesen, ich weiß auch nicht
der pretzelsnacker ist auch am start
was ist das?
hallo jungs, so wie es ist, hallo
das kenn ich, das hab ich schon vor jahren mal genau gesehen
ist das legal?
warum soll das nicht legal sein?
natürlich ist das legal
hast du gemacht, ja es ist mir schon klar, dass du das gemacht hast
ich mein, ich bin ja manchmal bisschen lowbrain, aber den zusammenhang zwischen dem channel
besitzer und deinem namen im chat, den hab ich auch erkannt
oh das wär schlecht, ich muss halt übrigens noch easy sellout fertig machen
ich wollte herzner nämlich bis morgen ne liste schicken, was wir alles machen können
ich hab mir ja schon ein paar sachen aufgeschrieben und es gibt ja total viele möglichkeiten
was man machen kann, ja von overlays im stream, man kann sogar im discord irgendwelche integrations
machen mit botcommands, hier im chat, botcommands, videobeschreibung, gibt ja alles mögliche
da wollt ich mir nächste woche mit denen raussuchen, was wir dann jetzt abschließend
jetzt uns überlegen, also was wir dann abschließend machen
dann gibt es beim nächsten mehr sellout leute
und heute mittag gibt es ein neues video 15.30, höchstwahrscheinlich zumindest 15.30
ich zwar, ich will mir gerade überlegen ob ich das mal teasern soll das video, ich teaser
das video mal, sack, ich muss bloß mal gucken wo ich es hab
ah ich hab es gar nicht auf dem rechner, geil da muss ich doch mal schnell runterladen
macht aber nix, gutschein für nicht, neukunde wäre nice, ich glaube das werden sie nicht
machen, ich glaube das werden sie nicht machen
weil die wollen ja gerade neukunden damit anlocken ne, can't wait, das wirds wahrscheinlich
nicht geben so ich tease mal kurz das aktuelle video
von heute aber nur die ersten 20 sekunden, weil ich will ja dass die leute das dann später
auf youtube gucken, ich muss nur mal kurz gucken wie ich das jetzt rüber auf den rechner
bekomme, 0w ja gut da kann ich dich nicht von abhalten
ne, aber letztendlich sind ja auch nur 20 euro, also wenn man da mehrere surfer hostet
sind da 20 euro auch schnell aufgebraucht ob sich das lohnt weiß nicht, was ist das
thema, ich hab ein video mit ihm zusammen hier aufgenommen, mit default skin im video
und wir lassen uns über die besten einsteiger programmiersprachen aus, das video geht relativ
relativ lang aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habs mir heute morgen mal angeguckt, das
ist finde ich das beste video was wir äh was es zu dem thema gibt im deutschsprachigen
bereich auf youtube finde ich, ist echt nice das hast du schonmal erzählt, ja ich hab
einige sachen schonmal erzählt also wenn ich den stream jetzt auf alles beschränke
was ich schonmal erzählt hab wirds ganz schön ruhig ne da dürfte ich auch wörter
nicht doppelt verwenden, genau, exellent, so jetzt gucke ich einmal, gibts hier die
möglichkeit das rüber zu kopieren, open folder, deck, copy, naja ok, mal schauen mal
schauen, aha ok gut kann ich aufs netzlaufwerk zugreifen, also ich tease jetzt mal das aktuelle
video, was heute mittag kommt, hallo, hallo leute hier ist der max und je nachdem auf welchem
channel ihr jetzt schaut werdet ihr euch vielleicht denken, was gibt das denn wenn es fertig ist
und das kann ich euch sagen, nämlich der florian von algorythm und verstehen und ich
hab uns gedacht wir machen mal ein video zusammen, bamm genug teaser oder, und zwar zu einem thema
was bei uns beiden immer sehr häufig nachgefragt wird und das ist, was ist die beste einsteiger
programmiersprache, so genug teaser, bamm, das ist das video für heute, laden wir heute
ein, ja, mach ich, man siehts ne, mach ich, null, ja, ich hab das mal bei mir lokal ausprobiert
ob das über den samper share geht, assembler, nein, nein, ich werd auch leute ich stell
euch doch kein c++ vor, meint ihr allen ernst dass ich würde c++ als einsteiger programmiersprache
vorstellen, ihr kennt mich, aber zscharp ist dabei, ja das stimmt, ihr kennt dass ich
Fanboy bin. HTML natürlich. Also wir stellen vor HTML, C-Sharp, Kobol und ABAP. Das sind
mit eindeutig die besten Einsteiger-Programmiersprachen. Na gut, das ist auch beides relativ gut für
ich mag jetzt ich mag ich mein ich mein ich mein ich hab gesagt ich empfehle das nicht
ja da sind ja auch ganz gute sprachen also gerade pice ist zum einstieg super java naja
es ist halt java ich bin kein großer java fan aber die kann man schon benutzen java
ist nicht so schlecht gerade wenn man kotlin verwendet oder ich hab mal das einzige projekt
auf jvm basis was basis was ich jemals gemacht habe war in groovy zu dem zeitpunkt wusste
ich gar nicht dass es diese programmiersprache überhaupt gibt aber die gibt's rust zum einstieg
ja das wäre es jetzt echt noch rust allah ich finde rust cool ich bin zu low brain ich
bin zu low brain für für rust ich hab in rust ein bisschen rumgebastelt schon ist es
aber schon ein bisschen her ich würd's mir gern mal wieder angucken aber ich bin ich
bin einfach zu low brain für rust wisst ihr ich mach das so ich mein rust ist zwar eine
coole sprache wenn man sicher gehen will dass man keinen mist programmiert weil es halt
sehr pingelig ist mit darauf achten ob irgendwelche variablen out of scope gehen oder was auch
immer also du machst also rust ist die programmiersprache schlechthin wo du noch am ersten sagen kannst
es kompiliert gleich es funktioniert also das ist in rust tatsächlich ziemlich gut
allerdings ich mach das eh anders das meiste was ich programmiere ist nicht großartig
sicherheitskritisch ich bastel das einfach ja ich führe das aus und wenns crash fix
ich den bug bis es nicht mehr crash und dann ist gut dann wirds released fertig ich brauch
die ganzen rust features nicht und jetzt irgendwelche kommentare in code ist eh overrated wir wissen
dass ihr alle guter code dokumentiert sich selbst so was gucken wir uns denn heute an
wir gucken uns das jetzt in der schleife an die ganze zeit aber ich hab das schon äußerst
synchron am anfang hingekriegt oder das ist echt nicht schlecht ja gut sap ist halt big
stonks ne sap bringt halt geld was lass lass mal ganz kurz gucken lass mal ganz ich muss
mir lass lass mal kurz schauen was kostet ein sohnen was wenn ich sap sap so sap in
haus sap ach so da steht ja kein geld dabei gehalt sap konsult was verdient man da so
wie mehr nett da muss doch da muss doch mehr gehen das ist so komische 100.000 euro nach
fünf jahren ja das kann ich mir schon eher vorstellen also sap ist auch so ein ding was
ich selbst was ich irgendwie selbst finanziert so so selbst finanzierendes ökosystem ein
bisschen wie diese ganzen komischen den iso eitel sonst was schulungen wisst ihr was
die schlimmste die die schlimmste qualitätssicherungs ne wie nennt man das wie wir was wie genau
nennt was sagt eigentlich eitel was es selber ist best practice leitfaden ok also die schlimmste
schulung im thema best practice leitfaden die ich jemals machen musste war nicht so
eitel eitel hat ja durchaus noch sinnvolle sachen das schlimmste was ich mal machen musste
war dien iso 9001 die norm im qualitätsmanagement ich mein allein schon wenn es eine qualitätsmanagement
norm ist nach dien stand da könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen da stimmt irgendwas nett
und ehrlich gesagt ich hab schon keine ahnung mehr ich kann mich schon überhaupt nicht
ich kann mich null dran erinnern hier gibt es den pdca zyklus was auch immer keine ahnung
mehr ich weiß nur das war extremst pains champig diese schulung zu machen die ging auch fast
eine woche damals jeden tag ganz ganz grausam was ist sap eigentlich irgendein buchhaltungsmanagement
stellz kram frag mich nicht die können alles mögliche wenn die norm auch nach 9001 überprüft
und dann ist die frage wer überprüft ob die dien normen 9001 überprüft auch nach dien
iso 9001 überprüft werden erp system kram ja ich bin froh dass ich mit sap nichts zu
tun hab das problem ist wenn ich so ein kram angucke ich krieg nur noch so ein mist empfohlen
jetzt ne fliegt wassapp raus ne wahrscheinlich nicht wassapp droht das aus da hab ich so
meine zweifel was ist eigentlich aus fortnite aus im store geworden was ist eigentlich
aus fortnite aus im ios store und so geworden gibts es noch moment muss ich mal gucken fortnite
apple store fortnite kann derzeit nicht auf iphone runter geladen werden aha weg ja steckt
uns jetzt wieder alles gut so zeigt uns ich hab schon ein paar videos aufgemacht zeigt
uns youtube mal irgendwas spannendes was wir noch was wir noch angucken müssen nix ja die
da seins berechtigung vom raspberry pi pico versteh ich ja ehrlich gesagt bis heut net
also ich hab echt keine ahnung warum man den verwenden sollte was soll das nächste
video werden postchamp vogue now tja das nächste video kam mir schon raus das nächste video
war kickstarter scam ich könnte als max wupplos omega 0 wupp et gmail mich sign innen wusste
gar nicht dass ich mir mal einen fake account gemacht hab
software testing explained in 100 sekunden wie gesagt gute software dokumentiert sich
selbst und funktioniert einfach ja ein raspberry pi pico mit wlan wäre pork es gibt ja ein
paar boards die wlan drauf haben aber halt nicht das offizielle fett test coral was
ach so fette fette kole ich hab ich hab ich hab pepo pepo fett ich hab gedacht da gehts
ums essen warum krieg ich videos mit dem typ empfohlen ich will das überhaupt nicht sehen
der typ triggert mich übelst durch die pure existenz in dem video ich will das will das
nicht sehen ich bin ich eingeloggt sonst könnte ich sagen interessiert mich nicht habt ihr
schon den ding den liegt bettel viel sechs trailer gesehen wir lassen es gleich wir lassen
uns gleich von von level cap g baiten wieder gucken ob sie irgendwas spannendes gibt irgendwas
spannendes was uns youtube heute empfehlen kann ja roborock ich mein mehrere tests dazu
muss ich mir auch nicht angucken ja irgendwie nix spannendes am start der typ baut sein
eigenes ps 5 case ok das 3d trucker stells jetzt halt mal ja gucken wir uns kann man
es gleich angucken ich guck ja gerne so handwerks videos an kennt ihr die videos die so so zinger
wo dann was weiß ich rest restoration alte schuhe rest restaurieren oder oder alte werkzeuge
restaurieren oder sowas gibt total viele videos auf youtube wo die irgendwelche alten werkzeuge
wieder glänzend machen das gucke ich mir unglaublich gern zum einschlafen an das hat
so was meditatives was hältst du von just in time lieferungen was sind denn just in
time lieferungen beim betrieb fresink gerade in wahren zulieferung ohne ein lager zu haben
ich kenne drop shipping was sind just in time lieferungen so nach dem motto ich habe was
bestellt und der typ steht schon vor der tür oder wie das kann man tatsächlich angucken
ja das kann man tatsächlich angucken wahrscheinlich das ist das also ich habe mich ich habe mich
noch nicht das können wir tatsächlich anschauen ein bisschen bisschen durch skippen ich könnte
mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass das so ein typisches ding wird gut gedacht aber die umsetzung
ist failbar microsoft ich habe nämlich zum beispiel gelesen dass dieser dass der microsoft
package manager weiß ich aber den github link überhaupt drin hat hier bin get dass
er nur manche pakete deinstallieren kann nur wenn sie im richtigen format sind das heißt
es ist immer noch so dass man sachen installieren kann die man mit dem paket manager wohl nicht
mehr deinstallieren kann was echt fail wäre
ich gucke mir immer messer restoration ja so zeug gucke ich mir auch gerne an irgendwelche
leute die so ein richtig alles rostiges messer haben und dann schleifen und machen die da
20 minuten dran rum und dann ist es wieder glänzen und dann da kann man gut bei einpennen
new original xbox easter egg das habe ich gelesen das ist eines der unspektakulärsten
easter eggs allerzeit du musst irgendwie sowas du musst du musst genau du musst audio kopieren
und dann siehst du den credits bildschirm das langweiligste easter egg ever es ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm dass es nicht gefunden wurde ok mit was fangen wir an trailer trailer
league rises big questions about battlefield reveal by the way level cap gaming weiß ganz
genau der weiß ganz genau was sache ist ich weiß es mittlerweile auch zum größten teil
aber ich darf es nicht verraten weil ich es unterschrieben habe dass ich es nicht verrate
aber ich finde es immer lustig wenn die leute es eigentlich wissen und so tun als als haben
sie keine ahnung ja das immer geil der tue weiß das ganz genau so ich muss jetzt nur
mal sound kurz ausmachen ja ich habe gestern gestern nda unterschrieben ich darf nix sagen
ich bin da ist eigentlich auch unter nda dass man nda unterschrieben hat keine ahnung ich
darf darf nix sagen also schauen wir uns mal an was hat er denn zu erzählen
ist das eigentlich immer noch so ich weiß nicht wie ich drauf komme ich glaube weil
ich den typ grad darfst du sagen ob es gut oder schlecht wird ich darf gar nichts sagen
es geht ja auch nicht um battlefield sondern um fifa ist das eigentlich immer noch so
ich weiß nicht wie ich grad drauf kommen dass man in pupke das lehnen umlegt also
ich hab ja mal auch ganz kurz pupke gespielt als es voll angesagt hat wo das jeder gespielt
hat dann da hat man so das pupke umgelegt also das lehnen umgelegt dass man quasi wenn
man nach rechts gelaufen ist sich nach links lehnt also sprich man hat q und e vertauscht
und so sachen macht man das immer noch
habt ihr den trailer gesehen das war ziemlich langweilig aber nachdem man den trailer im
video nicht zeigt könnte da ja was dran sein
ja warum zeigst du es denn nicht kollege wahrscheinlich hat er schiss dass es dann
die anzeige raus ist wenn das im video zeigt oder dass er probleme kriegt mit dice ich
würde es aber diesen leaked trailer auch nicht auf youtube veröffentlichen obwohl
im prinzip so im rahmen nach normaler berichterstattung der ja eigentlich nix dagegen spricht man
hat es ja nicht selbst geliegt leider war firestorm halt kacke wobei firestorm war gar
nicht so kacke es hatte viele elemente aus warzone schon drinne beispielsweise das mit
den platten aber es war halt so nicht für die aktuelle zeit passend vor allem weil
es halt was kostet schreckt moment soll das battlefield gameplay gewesen sein gerade ja
das war das war was ist das sieht ja aus wie wellfield 2 oder wie er tut als weiß er
das nicht wie er tut als weiß das nicht kacke weh
mal macht er in jedem seiner battlefield zusammenfassungs videos diesen jump mit diesem hovercraft rein
das ist das ist doch legit in jedem video was wir von dem die woche geguckt haben ist
das immer drin oder erinnert ihr euch auch jedes jedes video ist das drin natürlich kriegen
wir den battle royale mode also meiner persönlichen meinung nach das ist so sicher wie das abend
in der kirche klar gibt es ein battle royale mode muss es geben die lassen sich doch nicht
von warzone vormachen wie man easy money an zwölfjährigen und nicht nur zwölf stimmt
ja gar nicht an zwölf plus jährigen verdient fette kohle macht und wollen sich das nicht
wollen sich das nicht da auch was von ab haben zumal die leute nach der unfähigkeit von
raven software und dem das den leuten warzone ein bisschen zum hals raushängt ist es jetzt
genau der richtige zeitpunkt für so einen modern military setting battle royale ja ich
persönlich bin kein großer battle royale fans wissen ja und ich bin jetzt auch nicht
da mein battlefield braucht unbedingt ein battle royale aber rein aus finanzieller sicht
100 pro 100 pro wenn nicht wäre ich sehr stark verwundert
eine sache was sie ein bisschen problematisch haben die wollen ja wahrscheinlich auch skins
und gedöns verkaufen die in warzone haben den großen vorteil die können halt bekannte
charaktere verkaufen was durch die können saub verkaufen price verkaufen wutz verkaufen
wen es auch da noch alles gibt an skins battlefield muss halt ja mehr oder weniger original charaktere
und sachen und skins erfinden allerdings haben die ja auch genug games zum beispiel
was ich mega geil fände stellt euch mal vor es gibt einen battlefield 6 oder battlefield
oder wie auch immer es dann heißen wird battle royale modus und man könnte sich den medic
skin aus bett company 2 holen den specialist medic skin der mit der grünen der mit der
grünen mütze will ich haben hier den da den grünen den grünen den grünen mützen
medic den würde ich mir gleich holen
es könnte natürlich auch sein dass dies cross platform machen was das nicht cross platform
cross game machen dass es plans versus zombies skin gibt den bed hey ohne mist die idee ist
gar nicht schlecht da sind die bestimmt auch schon drauf gekommen die machen das bestimmt
cross platform es gibt einen momenten etio skin gibt es bestimmt nicht das ubisoft moment
ea spiele der letzten jahre ich habe das alles ziemlich ignoriert gibt einen fifa skin es
gibt einen fifa skin in battlefield battle royale wird mich alles nicht wundern die machen
einfach die machen einfach crossplay zwischen fifa und battlefield battle royale du kannst
ein team aus fifa import ich sollte die nicht auf ideen bringen ich sollte die nicht auf
ideen bringen alter ihr wisst genau bei sowas sind die sofort dabei du kannst dann dein
du kannst dann dein fifa pay to win team importieren
meinst du die holen die worson auch rambo skins anderer firmen ja wenn das spiel erfolgreich
ist auf jeden fall ich mein fortnite fortnite hat es im endeffekt vorgemacht fortnite hat
ja auch collaborated mit total viel zeug ja von von tomb raider bis dieses marvel zeug
und was es nicht alles gibt ja die haben ja alles mögliche gemacht und das wäre also
wenn das erfolgreich john wick und so genau genau und wenn das erfolgreich ist dann machen
die das hier auch geld haben die genug und die haben ja mit apex gelernt so ein bisschen
heraus wie man erfolgreich battle royale über die jahre hinweg betreibt ich meine apex hat
über eine milliarde an geld gemacht für ea schon da da gehen die stonks die stonks
zahlen in den augen hier hoch bei bei den bwl stellzern bei ea
die sollen auf jeden fall mal die ganze bett company reinpacken ich wollte schon immer mal
als miss july spielen die man glaube ich nie gesehen hat im spiel also können sie sich
ausdenken was es für eine skin ist es wird auf jeden fall es wird auf jeden fall free
to play sein garantiert die haben gelernt von firestorm und ich glaube auch nicht dass
es in firestorm 2.0 ist es mag sicherlich unter der haube einiges aus bett aus firestorm
raus gerippt haben code technisch aber das game wird vom look und allem das wird wahrscheinlich
firestorm die allzu viel zu tun haben ok es sieht es sieht einfach ok wetten das braucht
man nicht wetten das braucht man nicht außer in story mission wo es explizit heißt lasst
dich nicht erwischen versteckt deine waffe nein pass auf lasst deine waffe stecken ansonsten
wirst du es wahrscheinlich nie brauchen weil du alles umnietest mit dem schneiber mit
der schneiber oder mit dem bogen den bogen wird es garantiert auch wieder geben bogen
far cry ohne bogen geht ja nicht wobei ich habe far cry 5 nicht gespielt gabs in far
cry 5 in bogen bestimmt gabs in bogen oder wahrscheinlich muss muss bogen bogen in far
cry gibt es gibt es immer franchise es sieht halt absolut mal null nach realistischen waffen
aus ne new mechanic for far cry it doesn't make you invisible to enemies though get to
close the game's rpg mechanics are also mixing up the formula a bit instead of perks being
tied to your characters progression they're actually attached to your gear attributes
this should make it easier to switch up your play style for different missions es ist es
ist es ein zombie apokalypsen spiel oder was warum schieße ich gegner mit cds ich dachte
das sollten halbwegs ein halbwegs realistisches setting in der in der karibik oder so sein
far cry 6 warum warum schieße ich leute kaputt mit cds wenn es sein muss
war mein wann oktober gar nicht mehr so lange vier monate 7 oktober juni haben wir jetzt
juli julisram ja 5,5 4,5 monate ok mich null spielt einer von euch aktiv
fanbo tournament station site yields and revives anyone in its area of effect similar to how
Das war ich ich ne ich reite ja gerne drauf rum wenn ich richtig gelegen habe
So nach dem motto ich habe es euch schon immer gesagt aber da muss ich mal wirklich zugeben da habe ich falsch gelegen
Da habe ich echt falsch gelegen mit rainbow six sie ich
Ich habe gedacht gut ich mein der start war auch nicht gut das start war halt auch nicht gut
Ich habe damals echt gedacht so nach dem motto war ich nicht gut
Ich habe gedacht ich habe auch nicht gut
Nach dem motto was machen die da das ist nichts halbes und nichts ganzes merkwürdiges game und ist wahrscheinlich nach einem halben jahr tot
Hätte ich nicht gedacht
Hätte ich echt nicht gedacht dass es nach wieviel jahren vier jahre oder so ist es jetzt schon raus immer noch
Beliebt ist hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht da habe ich mal komplett falsch gelegen
Geht aber immer mehr den bach und da ich glaube ich weiß ja nicht wie viel du das spielst
Ich glaube diese sache mit geht immer mehr den bach runter
Ist ist meistens gar nicht so das denkt man ich kenne das das denkt man wenn man besonders intensiv sachen
verfolgt und spielt da denkt man mit der zeit so ah das wird immer schlechter zum beispiel genauso wie
CSGO geht auch immer mehr den bach runter und sowas in der richtung aber ich glaube von geld und spielerzahlen ist das gar nicht so
Und ich weiß nicht wie es bei rainbow six sie aussieht genau so wie beispielsweise
Bei jeder erweiterung world of warcraft erzählt wird so das game geht den bach und das game geht den bach und da okay das game ging
Auch ein bisschen den bach und aber es hat immer noch millionen spieler und
Ich glaube umso näher man an so sachen dran ist umso anfälliger ist man für sie für diese sachen mit geht den bach
Und da also ich weiß nicht ob es wirklich so ist kann das kann das schlecht
urteilen
Aber ich habe das selbst bei mir schon gemerkt
Ich habe ja auch immer gesagt alter call of duty geht den bach runter geht den bach runter was auch immer
Und jetzt mit worson hat es so viele spieler wie noch nie wobei ich halt sagen muss ich finde multiplayer technisch
Es ist auch total den bach runtergegangen gibt es wirklich noch irgendjemand der cold war oder modern war von multiplayer spielt um
Des multiplayer willens die meisten spielen den multiplayer doch nur um waffen schnell zu leveln für worson
Manche machen leak play ok das ist was anderes aber so den normalen
publik skill based matchmaking
multiplayer spielen die meisten auch nur waffen für worson hoch zu leveln gerade in dem moment ok
No rules
Vier monat dankeschön für den primes ab huge subscription
Ich denke schieftung der meta jetzt ein einziges mehle strich kann die schattere mirers schwarze mirers gadget und
bulletproof cameras this makes it impossible to see through them, but leaves them intact otherwise other changes coming with nor star include dead bodies
Disappearing saurus master dankeschön für den primes ab habe ich gar nicht gesehen huge sub fünf monate no longer creating holes through breakable walls
Balance changes to barrel attachments and melusi's gadget can be shot when inactive nor star is currently on the games test servers
So you can try all the changes out for yourself. Weiß jemand wird mich jetzt mal
Interessieren wie die wie die das mann wie ist das verhältnis von grill operators zu mail operators in
rainbow six siege
So 50 50 oder
Oder gibt es mehr kerle 50 50 ok also gut das heißt die achten darauf finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht in der aktuellen zeit
Ansonsten das schlimme ist ja mittlerweile wenn die nicht darauf achten würden gibt's wahrscheinlich einen riesen shitstorm was dann auch wiederum nicht gerechtfertigt wäre
Or to be a divisive update when it launched. Ja ich habe das den half life mal durchgespielt
Nein battlefield 6 wird noch nicht revealed
Und das egal
Leute Leute was was was welf so macht das muss nix werden erinnert sich noch jemand an steam machines
Die machines kennt noch jemand den steam controller
Die machen schon sachen die sind nicht so geil
Auf der anderen seite bringen sie sachen raus wie ihre vr prille und andere sachen die sind tatsächlich nice also welf macht wirklich hat wirklich so
So wir machen was und wenn es nicht taucht stellen was halt auch mal irgendwann wieder ein aber wir machen da kein großes tamtam drum
Ja steam os stimmt habe ich ja schon ganz vergesse
Offer wireless
Functionality like bluetooth and wi-fi in ist codename steam pal valve ceo gabe newall recently said during a panel q&a that the company would have something
Der ist auch der ist auch ganz schön alt gewonnen gaben oder
Der hat hier nur noch der hat ja mehr graue hand als ich gut der ist aber noch 20 jahre älter oder 25 jahre älter oder so
Aber da ist der ist ja auch schon da ist ja auch schon alt
Wo habe ich eigentlich mein gaben emote hier
Ist schon ist schon alt geworden
Die wollen jetzt eine switch machen ja sollen sie mal die switch ist vom konzept geil das problem ist nur das gibt halt keine games ist so die typische nintendo geschichte
Du kannst es gibt eine handvoll games für die switch die sind cool ansonsten kommt nichts gibt nichts
Also wenn ich mir irgendwann mal wenn ich mir irgendwann mal eine brille kauft dann steht das als erstes an
Ist doch müll ist doch müll auch müll
Ich weiß gar nicht warum die alles so scharf auf eine switch pro sind dass dann die spiele auf der normalen switch dann mal gescheit laufen oder wie warum
Die screen better stand 4k output support and more blumbergs report suggest that nintendo will reveal the new console around
These rumors basically since they began call of duty cold war is free to play weekend in celebration of memorial day you can jump in until june 1st and play either multiplayer or zombies outbreak mode
Also live for all players in warzone news yet another twitch rivals competitor has also been banned following the january 2021 tournament runner up in mvp of the event america has been banned by twitch following widespread allegations
That he's cheating in both warzone and black ops core war
Was ist wer ist wer ist das america the great twitch twitter twitter
Er ist der typ ne okay ich habe keine ahnung wer das ist ernsthaft kein schimmer
Der typ hat 900 follower auf twitter das kann nicht der richtige sein wenn das irgendein bekannter typ ist
Warum also wenn irgendwann jetzt mal ernsthaft wenn irgendjemand in irgendeinem forum vor 20 jahren oder vor 5 jahren mal irgendwie cheat sich für irgendein x beliebiges anderes game besorgt hat
Da kann man es jetzt ja wohl schlecht als als beleg dafür nehmen dass der in dem turnier gecheatet hat oder also ich meine sogar ich habe schon mal cheats verwendet
Von von single player games bis irgendwie just for fun multiplayer zeug teilweise auch aber ich habe nie irgendwelche competitive dinger gecheatet oder ich würde auch nie mmos schieten oder sowas ja stellt euch vor sogar ich habe schon mal cheats benutzt
Ich meine ich bin nicht in form gegangen habe gesagt ich will ich will stream sichere cheats haben ja aber ich meine allein schon wenn man weil man ein bisschen
Bisschen neugierig ist ja ich habe früher auch mal ausprobiert cs 1 CS 052 war das noch ich habe auch mal irgendwelche sachen ausprobiert einfach weil ich neugierig war wie das ausschaut ja wenn du kästchen um gegner hast das ist das was war ich 15 jahr her davon jetzt auszugehen dass ich jetzt jedes jegliches competitive match cheaten würde ist doch bescheuert
Ich glaube die ohne schaus ohne scheiß ich glaube die meisten die die früher mal cs gespielt haben oder sowas und irgendwo mal einen download gesehen haben die haben es halt mal ausprobiert und was ja auch dazu beigetragen hat
Die hälfte cs gopros haben schon mal in einem alten cs teil gecheatet ja wundere mich auch nicht das heißt ja nicht bei weitem nicht dass man das in einem pro match macht ja ich fand es halt einfach interessant und das hat mit dazu beigetragen dass ja zu dem dass ich zu dem schluss gekommen bin was jetzt über cheats denke was ich heute denke ich finde cheaten an sich nicht schlimm ich finde es halt in pvp environments wo es um
quasi um das mit und gegen andere spieler spielen geht scheiße wenn jetzt irgendjemand sich keine ahnung xbox erfolge xbox achievements er cheatet mit irgendeinem save game oder irgendjemand singleplayer sein zeug cheatet juckt mich nicht wenn irgendjemand beispielsweise mal auf was weiß ich auf ein auf ein free to play
crossfire server join da ein paar cheats an hat das juckt mich alles nicht wirklich es kommt immer auf dieses auf das umfeld an und davon jetzt auszugehen dass irgendjemand automatisch nur weil er in irgendeinem game market cheat an hatte jetzt auch in einem competitive modus cheatet ist halt fail
ja zum beispiel ohne scheiß wenn jemand auf den minecraft server geht ja und ich meine das game ist halt offen wie ein scheudentor wenn einer auf dem minecraft server geht und da flyhack anmacht oder so da gehe ich doch jetzt nicht davon aus dass der danach in seinem nächsten faceit match cheatet das einer hat
mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun
full of clips floating around but being caught looking for cheats is a pretty surefire way of attracting accusations the latest update for microsoft flight simulator has cut the games initial install size in half from 170 gigabytes to just 83 the games listing on the microsoft store says it requires about 127 gigabytes by either way it's a massive
ok update das ist ja fast schon warzone größer update 172 nee 127 update für flight simulator nicht schlecht ist ja fast warzone neu installiert
was zum geier soll das sein
das ist wo ihr das
da hat ihre ihre ihre foto gedingt bisschen bisschen bisschen gefällt oder das sieht von der beleuchtung her und irgendwie nicht richtig aus ich meine das sieht schon geil aus das game
der
da
hat
dann
wenn
Es gibt immer noch 2D-Städte in Flight Simulator, da wird es wahrscheinlich auch immer geben,
weil die können ja schlecht die ganze Welt von Hand modeln.
Was weiß ich, die können schlecht irgendein komisches Ureinwohner-Dorf im Dschungel im
Kongo 3D modeln.
Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Was weiß ich, das Zulul-Dorf im Kongo muss nicht 3D gemodelt sein im Flight Simulator.
Das reicht, wenn man da etwas größeren hat.
Es sei denn, die würden irgendwelche Community Contributions davon nehmen oder irgendwelche
Plugins erlauben.
Dann könnte jemand, der eben aus so einem Dorf kommt oder aus der Region und sagt,
ich will, dass meine Region gut gemodelt ist, das machen, aber naja, gibt Schlimmeres.
Doch, die lassen sich aus 2D Maps 3D generieren, aber das funktioniert halt an manchen Stellen
gut, an manchen Stellen schlecht.
Am besten funktioniert es, wenn man das als Basis nimmt und dann manuell noch was mitmacht.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Battlefield 1 Sniping, nein.
Können diese Empfehlungen für diese komischen Videos endlich mal weggehen?
Der Auer hat ein neues Video.
Unreal Engine 5, I have seen the future, naja.
Also ich muss sagen, a day in the life of an engineer working from home, ok, zeig her.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Das stimmt bei mir schon mal nicht.
12 Uhr aufstehen, nope.
Sag mal, eine der, wisst ihr, was mir da auffällt bei der Sache, wenn ich das so sehe, kann
es sein, dass sich bei Smartphones die letzten 3, 4 Jahre nichts mehr getan hat, außer,
dass die Dinger mehr Kameras bekommen?
Das sieht genauso aus, ist genauso schnell, kann genau das gleiche, kriegt aber immer
mehr Kameras.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, das sieht bei mir auch manchmal abends so aus, weil alle
der Meinung sind, sie müssen schreiben, wenn sie jetzt heimgehen.
Ich hau 15.30, 16 Uhr so ab von der Arbeit und dann guck ich abends mal so aufs Handy
in meinen Notifications und hab dann irgendwie 13 Notifications.
Schönes Wochenende, macht's gut.
Wir sehen uns.
Welches Handy hast du?
Pass auf, ich muss jetzt mal den WeirdChamp Flex starten, ich hab nen iPhone SE, ich
hab nen iPhone 6, ich hab nen iPhone XR und ich hab nen iPhone 11 und ich glaub mittlerweile
13 Android Tablets und zwei iPads.
Ich weiß, WeirdChamp Flex, weiter gehts Video.
Ich weiß nicht, wem's in Teams schon mal passiert ist, Teams hat ja neuerdings so nen
Knopf da oben, Moment, Meet Now, so, Teams hat ja neuerdings nen Knopf da oben, da kann
man quasi ohne, dass man nen Termin im Kalender macht, nen Meeting Raum erstellen und dann
Leute einladen.
Das ist ja ganz cool, das Dumme ist nur, dass es den exakt gleichen Knopf auch in Teams
Chaträumen gibt, der heißt da ein bisschen anders, aber der ist genau an der gleichen
Stelle.
Das Fatale ist, klickst du hier drauf, macht das nen Meeting Raum auf und du kannst Leute
einladen, bist du in Teams und klickst oben drauf, lädst du mit einem Klick alle ein
aus dem Channel, was dann teilweise auch mal 40 Leute sein können, zu irgendeinem Meeting,
das ist wirklich Pepega Platzierung von Microsoft da, keine Ahnung, ob schon mal einem von euch
passiert ist, aber, ist bisschen unglücklich platziert, weiß nicht, ob man das hier irgendwie
sieht, ist bisschen, ist echt unglücklich platziert.
Ich hab das auch schon mal gehabt, ich hab's vergessen, da war ich grad beim Mittagessen,
da hatte ich auch irgendein Meeting, hab ich vergessen und ich hab auch nicht gesehen,
dass es 15 Minuten vorher Bescheid gesagt hat, irgendwann haben die mich angerufen und
da hab ich gesagt, ja ich bin gleich da, ich bin nur grad mal kurz noch auf dem Klo gewesen
und die Möglichkeit saß ich unten eine halbe Stunde und hab gefuttert, halbe Stunde krieg
ich eh Zeit abgezogen.
Das ist, das ist so ein typisches, typisches Meeting Gelaber, sowas gibt's bei uns auch,
sowas gibt's bei uns auch, das ist auch teilweise echt geil, wenn dich irgendeiner fragt, also
die Standard Antwort, wenn dich irgendeiner fragt, und wie sieht's denn damit aus und
du hast keine Ahnung, was der Typ gerade meint oder dir fällt ein Fakt, das hab ich vergessen,
du sagst einfach, da sind wir gerade dran, das ist so, das ist so, diese Antwort schluckt
fast jeder, da sind wir gerade dran, ich war eben grade, hab ich noch danach geguckt, da
sind wir gerade dran, da geht's voran und ah okay passt, weiter geht's, da schärfen
wir nach, ja das ist auch was, was ich letztens gelernt hab, das ist so ne schöne, so ne schöne
Phrase, die ist, die ist auch bei uns grad angesagt, wenn irgendwas nicht gut funktioniert
hat, dann sagen die Leute dann nicht, ah das war kacke oder das müssen wir uns nochmal
angucken und besser machen, die sagen dann, wir schärfen nochmal nach.
Ah by the way, das machen übrigens alle ne, also das ist auch so, wenn du, wenn du
keine Ahnung, irgendwie deinen Chef oder sonst was fragst und er hat noch nicht geguckt,
dann sagt er auch, da sind wir gerade dran, das ist so die Standard Antwort irgendwie
bei uns und es klappt immer.
Das nehmen wir mit, das nehmen wir mit auch, ja.
Ja, das, das, das kommt bei uns nicht vor, das klappt eigentlich.
Jetzt macht er, jetzt, ich glaub ich weiß, was in den Videos kommt, jetzt macht er erstmal
Twitch auf und guckt zwei Stunden Livestream oder sowas, by the way, das ist richtig Poggers
Büro hier, was der am Start hat, guck mal da, curved, curved 32 Zoll oder was ist das
für ein Bildschirm, oben noch ein Bildschirm, da zwei Bildschirme, richtig Poggers, da kann
ich mit meinen zwei Bildschirmen und dem Streamingrechner, normalen Rechner nicht mithalten.
Vor allem, was ist denn das für eine Maus, huge ergonomisch, ups, hab ich grad verdrückt,
so schlecht sah das doch jetzt gar nicht aus, dieser Sound, der Sound triggert, ne Leute,
beachtung, das brauch ich, das brauch ich in meinem Board, Leute, unbedingt, da kann
ich die Leute schocken im Stream, Teams Message Sound, jawoll, das brauch ich, ich mein ich
hab ICQ schon drinnen, das brauch ich, wichtig, wichtig, YouTube, YouTube DL, bitte nicht
Sonntags, FFmpeg-i, wie heißt das, Microsoft Teams Notification, Teams Sound WAF, perfekt,
Local Host, so, wo hab ich das jetzt, jetzt, Explorer, Teams Sound WAF, jawoll, Ed, oh,
das ist auch noch so schön, so schön subtil im Hintergrund, da denken alle immer, sie kriegen
eine Message, das ist nice, das brauch ich ab und zu mal für, gbaited, gbaited, ok weiter,
man sieht aber den Status, dass er nicht ermieten ist, ich mach übrigens auch, ja, ich mach
auch nie Webcam an, ich mach immer nur Webcam an, wenn es irgendwie was wichtiges ist und
die anderen da auch Webcam an haben oder irgendeiner sagt, können wir mal, was manche ganz gerne
machen bei uns in den Meetings, weiß nicht, ob das bei euch auch so ist, die machen gerne
so ein Gruppenfoto in Teams, da gibt es auch die Möglichkeit, dass man alle, dass man alle
so auf eine Seite einblendet und es gibt Leute, die machen unglaublich gerne Gruppenfotos
in Teams, ich weiß nicht, warum, ja und das ist nervig, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, das gibt es bei uns auch manchmal, ja, wobei es eher so ist, nicht, dass die Kinder
im Hintergrund schreien, das ist eigentlich selten mittlerweile so, das haben die Leute
schon im Griff, es ist eher so, dass die Leute es immer noch nicht geschaffen, auf die Reihe
kriegen oder nicht schaffen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise ihre Soundsettings oder gescheites
Equipment zu haben, das hört sich dann echt an als sitzen sie gerade rauf auf dem Mikrofon
oder verstehst nix, ist entweder übersteuert als fuck, Blinder, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, das ist echt gut.
Ne finde ich nicht, der Chat sagt grad, naja gescheites Equipment sollte der Arbeitgeber
stellen.
Was willst du denn machen?
Ich mein 20 Euro für ein gescheites Mikrofon mal ausgeben, für ein gescheites USB Mikrofon
dadurch, da kann man besser arbeiten.
Du musst dich letztendlich auch darum kümmern, dass wenn du mit dem Auto zur Arbeit fährst,
da kannst du auch nicht sagen, ich komm nicht auf die Arbeit, weil ich kein Auto gestellt
bekomme.
Oder ich komm nicht, ich fahre nicht auf die Arbeit, weil ich kein Jobticket bekomme.
Also ja, ich seh das auch, so der Arbeitgeber sollte dich der Möglichkeit mit gutem Equipment
versorgen.
Aber gerade im zweistelligen Eurobereich kann man doch durchaus mal das Geld in die Hand
nehmen und sich gescheites Equipment kaufen, man braucht hier kein audiofiles super 10.000
Euro Equipment, um gescheite Homeoffice Qualität zu machen.
Moment, programmiert er da allen Ernstes, Moment, Moment, Moment, in Zykwin, wer macht
denn sowas?
Nee, Moment, warte mal, es sah gerade so aus, muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Das sieht, das sieht das, nee ist es nicht, aber es könnte tatsächlich sogar ein Gnome
Terminal oder so sein, aber wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist es Windows Stells.
Ja, die Leute das integrierte Mikrofon verwenden und dann drauf tippen, ist auch abartig.
Was macht der da, log, Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, Info, ist es, ist es etwa C++?
Ist das, ist es etwa C++, seh ich das richtig?
Ja, es ist C++.
Static Cast in 64t, Pains Champ, richtiger Pains Champ.
Da fehlen einige Simikolon, äh, da, ne?
Da fehlt ein Simikolon, da fehlt auch eins, ja gut, er debuggt ja auch, ne, da auch, fehlt
einiges.
Aber Static Cast, das muss ein C++ sein, ich hab übrigens letztens was Pains Champiges
gehört auf einem unserer Meetings, wenn dann Schleife, was soll das sein, do while oder
was, ey, das ist auch, das ist mega ätzend, das ist bei uns auch so, du, du kannst dich
kaum auf irgendwas konzentrieren, weil laufend irgendwas ist, und sei es nur, dass Messages
aufploppen, so nach dem Motto, äh, ach Leute, ich fang jetzt mit Home Office an, ach Leute,
ich heu heute ein bisschen früher mit Home Office auf, also ich hab schon ganz vieles
Zeug einfach gemutet, weil's mich, weil's mich, weil's mich nervt, ja, dann kommt Outlook
an mit irgendwelchen Geschichten, so nach dem blim, in 15 Minuten ist Daily, äh, Statusrunde,
bla bla bla, das ist nervig, ja.
Das ist vor Ort aber nicht wirklich besser.
Doch ich mag es auch, ich bin echt
Blinder.
Alright, we can take this offline for another time.
What were you saying?
Yeah, do you have any questions about the design?
Oh yeah, here's the thing.
I don't see machine learning anywhere in your proposal.
Und Blockchain fehlt auch noch.
We sell blinds to customers.
No, no.
We sell privacy.
We sell security.
We sell...
Blockchain.
The peace of mind.
And window blinds are merely the means for that. With machine learning, of course.
Oh, okay.
What data sets are we working with?
Are you collecting their feedbacks? Their returns?
Wait, did you not hear a word I said?
We are all about privacy, so we would never collect data from our customers.
Actually, I think I understand our intellectual discrepancy.
Oral communication, it's low bandwidth medium, I get it.
It's not your fault.
Let me just show you a PowerPoint of our design.
I think it will make a lot more sense once you see the diagram.
Es gibt tatsächlich auch echt so Leute, die nerven mich auch.
Die meinen, man würde sie nicht verstehen, weil es zu schlau ist, was sie sagen.
Dabei ist es oftmals einfach nur wir, was sie sagen.
Alright, do you see my screen?
I see your screen, but I don't think you're sharing the right one.
There we go.
So you understand now, right?
The innovation.
Just a second.
Sorry, I had a delivery come in.
Yeah, we'll look into that.
Do you have a team of machine learning engineers to work with us?
No, why would we?
Well, how are you going to maintain all this new technology in your system?
Well, that's for you guys to figure out.
Isn't that the whole point of your team?
Anyways, I gotta go.
Oh, one more thing.
Blockchain.
Blockchain, jawoll.
So, perfekt.
Ohne Blockchain geht nichts.
I'm sorry.
Sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie Blobcat.
Das ist eher Blobdog.
Blim.
Ich wusste es, ich wusste es, dass jetzt der Team Sounds kommt.
Oh nein, der war nicht von mir.
Der ist von mir jetzt.
Einfach stumm schalten.
Easy.
Sorry about the angle.
Ja, naja, jetzt natürlich ist es absichtlich jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es ist
schon viel wahres dabei.
Was ich auch immer lustig finde, kennt ihr das, wenn es Leute gibt, die immer nachfragen
müssen, aus Prinzip, auch wenn es nichts zum Nachfragen gibt?
Wir haben zum Beispiel einmal bei uns in der Woche so eine Runde, da werden so aktuelle
Wartungsarbeiten besprochen, was die Leute vorhaben.
Ja, dann sagt dann zum Beispiel einer, was weiß ich, wir machen neue Feierwollenregeln
für VPN Zugänge.
Der nächste kommt, ja, wir machen einen Exchange Upgrade.
Dann erzähle ich so nach wie was, ja, wir machen jetzt neue DovCod-Versionen auf allen
Linux-Servern oder irgendwie sowas.
So, das wird dann alles gesagt, gesagt, gesagt.
So, Runde ist fertig.
Dann sagt dann derjenige, der die Runde moderiert, sagt dann, ja, wenn es sonst nichts mehr gibt,
dann sehen wir uns.
Und dann kommt der Typ, ich hätte da doch mal eine Frage zum DovCod-Update auf Linux.
Sagt, ja, was für eine Frage.
Habt ihr damit auch mit den Verantwortlichen in Hongkong gesprochen?
Sagt, hä, was hat das jetzt damit zu tun?
Ja, da war ich letztens auf so einer Veranstaltung, die haben gesagt, sie verwenden auch DovCod.
Ich wollte jetzt bloß mal nachfragen, ob es dort nicht, dass es dort zu Problemen kommt.
Dann denke ich, Alter, was willst du von mir?
Das war jetzt natürlich ausgedacht, aber so Fragen kommen dann immer.
Dann denke ich, Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Was will der Kerl?
Und das sind immer die gleichen Leute, die nachfragen.
Nächste Woche ist es der gleiche Typ, der sagt, wir machen neue Firewall-Regeln für VPN-Zugänge.
Und dann kommt wieder der gleiche Typ, der, by the way, weder was mit Linux-DovCod-Updates zu tun hat,
noch mit Firewall-Updates.
Keine Ahnung, das ist dann ein Typ, der kommt zum Beispiel aus dem Bereich von irgendwelchen...
Keine Ahnung, Atlassientools oder so.
Da haben wir tatsächlich den eigenen Bereich für.
Ja, und die Woche drauf fragt er dann so Dinge wie, ihr habt ja auch mal drüber nachgedacht,
dass wenn ihr VPN-Firewall-Regeln updatet, wenn die Leute aus unserem 24-7-Support daran arbeiten,
dass sie dann auch nachts von daheim noch was machen können.
Der hat nichts damit zu tun, aber die müssen immer nachfragen.
Es gibt Leute, die fragen die unsinnigsten Sachen, und es sind immer die gleichen Leute.
Und es sind immer die gleichen Leute, und ich hab bis heute nicht verstanden,
warum die Leute das nachfragen.
Offensichtlich nicht, weil es sie interessiert, weil das, was da rauskommt,
ist nie eine sinnvolle Antwort, hat meistens mit dem Thema nichts zu tun.
Ich glaube, das ist... Ich glaube, der Pavilion-Man im Chat hat recht.
Ich glaube, das ist, dass die Leute wollen so tun, als sind sie voll engagiert.
Ja, aber dann fragst du doch irgendwas nach, was dich in irgendeiner Art und Weise betrifft,
und denkst dir nicht on the fly, irgendwas aus irgendeinem x-beliebigen Bereich,
der mit deinem überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Und das sind ja Sachen, die da gefragt werden, die gibt es teilweise gar nicht mal.
Also das ist, wenn man sich mit dem Bereich auskennt, weiß man, dass es dort keine Probleme geben kann.
Ja, das ist ungefähr so. Ich bringe euch mal ein Real-Life-Beispiel.
Ich bringe euch mal ein Real-Life-Beispiel.
Bei uns ist das einmal so, also wie gesagt, ich bin ja bei einer Bank,
hab ich schon öfters erzählt, und wir generieren an verschiedenen...
Das sind so ganz fett rot markiert im Kalender, gibt es dort gewisse Daten.
Was ist denn das Mehrzahl von Daten?
Also mehrere Dates im Kalender, wo Berichte generiert werden.
Zum Beispiel unter anderem, was irgendwelche Außendienstleute für Provision bekommen oder so.
Das ist ganz furchtbar wichtig für alle.
Und an diesen Terminen darf dann auch nichts Großartiges passieren.
Aber es ist ja vollkommen klar, dass es auf einem recht kleinen Bereich beschränkt ist.
Also sprich, daran ist beteiligt, im Endeffekt Datenbank und ein paar Server, die den Kram generieren.
Das war's. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre da das ganze Unternehmen von abhängig.
Und dann kommen dann solche Nachfragen wie, ja, also ich hab meine Bedenken...
Das ist kein Witz, das ist wirklich zwar ein bisschen geändert,
aber im Prinzip das, was wirklich so gefragt wird bei uns in der Runde.
Also es wird gesagt, ok passt auf Leute, am 30.05. ist eine Berichtsgenerierung.
Passt mal auf, dass ihr nichts im Bereich Datenbanken macht.
Und dann kommt ein anderer Typ an und sagt, ah, also ich hab da gesehen, in unserer Wartungsarbeitenübersicht,
am 30.05. werden Wartungsarbeiten an einer Telefonanlage durchgeführt.
Da möchte ich gern mal ein Veto einlegen, weil das hat konfliktet hier mit Reports generieren.
Dann denke ich mir, was zum Teufel hat Reports auf der Datenbank generieren mit der fucking Telefonanlage zu tun?
Das ist so die typische Sache, die Leute haben so was fragen, die haben keinen Plan,
müssen aber trotzdem aus Prinzip einfach fragen.
Es ist ätzend, ja.
Gut, genug gerantet.
Wir haben bei uns einen, der beendet jedes seiner Sätze mit ne.
Das ist auch teilweise echt ein wenig belastend.
Der sagt dann so, ich hab jetzt das neue Paket installiert, ne.
Und dann hab ich geguckt, dass danach der Dienst richtig gestartet ist, ne.
Und dann hab ich mich auf dem zweiten Server eingeloggt, ne.
Das ist auch ein wenig belastend, wenn ihr zu telefoniert.
Ja, die gibt's auch.
Aber ich sehe, wir haben alle mehr oder weniger die gleichen Probleme.
Wir haben alle mehr oder weniger die gleichen Probleme.
Ja klar, du, wenn du ja jemand bist, der von der Technik nicht so viel Ahnung hat,
da ist es vollkommen in Ordnung nachzufragen.
Und du fragst dir dann wahrscheinlich auch nach, weil du es verstehen willst.
Was ich meine ist, Leute, die es eigentlich besser wissen müssten
und random irgendwelche sinnlosen Fragen stellen.
Nur, dass sie Redezeit haben.
Keine Ahnung, weiß auch nicht warum.
Aber die sind auch geil. Die Leute sind auch geil, ne.
Dann erzählst du dann irgendwas so nach dem Motto, was weiß ich.
Ja, also Leute, ich hab's mir jetzt überlegt.
Wir machen es folgendermaßen.
By the way, machen wir schon.
Wenn ihr Feature Branches im Git macht, guckt doch, dass ihr euer Kürzel an Anfang schreibt,
damit ich erkennen kann, von wem das ursprünglich erstellt wurde
und dass ich nachgucken kann, ob da nicht jetzt irgendetwas passiert ist.
So, und dann gibt's Leute, die sagen danach, Max, das heißt also,
ich schreib dann am Anfang von dem Branch mein Kürzel, oder?
Ja, ich hab's doch gesagt.
Wir gucken erst mal den Kürzel am Anfang vom Branchen abschreiben.
Okay, das heißt, ich mach jetzt einen neuen Branch auf
und schreib dann am Anfang, Max slash mein Feature Branch.
Ja, ist das so richtig?
Ja, sag ich doch.
Das haben wir auch.
Das ist schon geil. Es gibt überall so die gleichen Leute.
Ja, gibt's auch.
Das wäre so eine typische Frage.
Die fände ich okay.
Die ist zwar ein bisschen zum Trollen.
Die Frage geht auch, wie heißt das?
Underscore oder Minus? Die Frage ist aber berechtigt.
Dann würde ich sagen, nein, das geht nicht,
weil Git, wie heißt das?
Namespaces sind halt eben nur mal mit Slash.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt's auch ein Problem mit Minus.
Wir haben relativ viel Puppet im Einsatz für Config-Management
und Puppet mag Minus in Ordnernamen nicht.
Was Ordnernamen?
In Environment-Namen nicht, genau.
Und nachdem ich oftmals Branch-Name gleich Environment-Name mache
zum Testen von Config-Management-Änderungen,
funktioniert das nicht.
Also das wäre eine legitime Frage.
Oder was, ein Slash war es nicht funktioniert?
Ich weiß es nicht. Zumindest ist es eine legitime Frage.
Betge.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Finally Windows got a Package-Manager.
Here is why it's aw-
Ich hab so meine Zweifel, dass das awesome ist.
Es ist eine geile Sache, dass Windows ein Package-Manager bekommt,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass der Package-Manager so richtig gut ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja.
Die haben ja schon zu Windows 10 übrigens hier.
Max FPS, Windows 10.
Das erste Windows 10 Video, was ich gemacht habe.
Moment, das ist das Falsche.
Hallo, ich hab doch ein Windows 10 angeschaut.
Oder wie hab ich es denn genau?
Ich hab doch ein Windows 10 Video angeschaut.
Ich hab doch ein Windows 10 Video gemacht.
Ganz am Anfang 2015 oder so, als das neu war.
Das da.
So, und da zeige ich auch schon den Package-Manager.
Irgendwo.
Und der hat, das heißt, die haben sechs Jahre gebraucht für ein Package-Manager.
Der hat immer richtig funktioniert.
Ja, hier, Find Package.
Genau.
Oder hat auch schon nicht richtig funktioniert.
So, dann schauen wir uns das jetzt mal an.
KQ8, wo ist...
Ach, da.
Right now.
Oh.
Ah, Moment, ich muss mal kurz Discord gucken.
Wobei, ich lasse einfach laufen.
Das Video, by the way, das Video,
was ich vorhin angeteased hat, mit Algorithmen verstehen,
machen wir wahrscheinlich erst morgen 15.30 Uhr.
Nicht heute 15.30 Uhr.
Ich weiß, Zedge, aber wir müssen noch ein paar Sachen im Video ändern.
Ich habe gerade im Discord gelesen.
So ein paar Kleinigkeiten müssen wir noch ändern.
Dafür wird das Video noch besser.
So.
Nehmt man da nicht Choco, das Problem ist,
dass es eben nicht offiziell ist.
Also, ein Package Manager von Microsoft
ist schon
the way to go.
Was ich nicht so ganz verstehe, ist,
die haben mit dem Windows Store ja prinzipiell
einen Package Manager,
den man vielleicht ein gescheiteres UI spendieren könnte
oder ein Kommando-Zeilen-Interface.
Das Problem ist, dass da halt nichts drin ist.
Ja, es ist komisch.
Keine Ahnung, was Microsoft da macht.
Hast du mit deinem Chef gesprochen
gegen Gehaltsleak? Ja, habe ich.
Darf ich machen, ist nicht verboten.
Weil es halt kostet im Store.
Wieso? Man kann auch kostenlose in Store machen.
Also, die haben ja im Prinzip was.
Ich wette mit euch, Microsoft verkackt das
mit dem Package Manager.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie das hinbekommen.
Ne, in den Store zu packen
kostet auch mittlerweile, glaube ich,
nichts mehr.
Du kriegst sogar ein kostenloses
Zertifikat und sowas. Das ist, glaube ich,
alles mittlerweile tatsächlich gar nicht so schlimm.
Du kannst aber nicht alles veröffentlichen,
was du willst im Store. Das ist das hauptsächliche
Problem.
Ich glaube,
da mach ich mir eine Video-Video-Idee.
Da mach ich auch mal ein Video zu.
Windows
Package Manager.
Wir brauchen einen guten Titel dafür.
Ich hätte eine Idee. Es muss ein bisschen clickbaity
sein.
Revolutioniert
das
Windows?
Ne, was? Leute,
Big Brain Time Titel.
Wir brauchen einen guten Titel dafür.
Wenn man
abt, abt auf mich
bestellt.
Das finde ich gut. Das
Dumme ist nur, dass auf YouTube
das keiner checkt.
Das kann ich aber auf Thumbnail schreiben.
Auf mich bestellt.
Linux nun
überflüssig.
Okay, ich überleg mir irgendwas.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Genau,
er hat.
Deswegen, das versteht auf YouTube keiner.
Das ist das Problem.
Das muss ein Titel sein,
den man versteht.
Für dich
nein, nein, nein.
Du meinst jetzt ein Package Manager?
Nein, das ist für dich nicht wurscht.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was auch einem normalen
User passieren kann. Das heißt ja nicht, dass
es ein Kommando-Zeilen-Programm sein muss, letztendlich.
Aber Programme aus der zentralen
Quelle installieren, ist
auch das Beste, was einem Casual-User passieren
kann. Weil dann muss sich keiner mehr darum
kümmern, dass er seine Programme updated
oder es vielleicht vergisst.
Und es muss nicht mehr jedes Programm seinen eigenen
Updater mitliefern. Das ist eigentlich das
Beste, was Casual-Leuten
passieren kann, ein ordentlicher Package
Manager für Windows. Du hast auch nicht mehr das
Problem, dass du dir irgendwo im Internet
Dinge suchen musst, runterladen
und
dann feststellen, oh, da war ja ein Virus drin
oder was auch immer, weil du dich von der falschen Seite runtergeladen hast,
was auch immer. Also das hat
fast
nur Vorteile, wenn das ordentlich gemacht
ist.
Was ist das eigentlich für
eine Big-Brain-Animation?
Gibt's da
auch Nachteile?
Eigentlich gibt's
im Ernst, wirklich Nachteile gibt's
bei einem Package Manager nicht, weil du kannst
ja auch Sachen so zusätzlich installieren,
wenn du das jetzt machen willst.
Also wenn du jetzt was installieren willst, was vielleicht nicht
im Package Manager drin ist oder eine neuere Version
oder eine ältere Version oder was auch immer,
du kannst ja immer noch manuell installieren.
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was es für Nachteile haben sollte.
Ja, gut, das juckt nicht.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, aber die ganze
Config und so, das ist...
die meisten
Leute haben doch, wenn man ehrlich ist,
gar nicht so viel installiert. Die meisten Leute haben
vielleicht, keine Ahnung, 10, 20 Programme
installiert und
ich meine davon
jetzt nicht Spiele, die man dann über Steam nachinstalliert.
Was haben die meisten Leute installiert? Die haben Steam, Origin,
Spotify, Discord,
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Textverarbeitungen, Mailprogramm und sonst
viel. Die meisten Leute haben 10, 20 Programme installiert. Das ist
kein großes Ding.
Teamspeak,
Photoshop,
Teamspeak.
Ah, okay, vielleicht 30.
Leute, ich muss unbedingt
meinen 3D-Keks fertig machen,
dass ich auch so Videos machen kann.
Dann stelle ich mich einfach hin und dann redet
der 3D-Keks mit euch.
Exzellent.
Dann brauche ich mich nicht mehr im Hintergrund,
sondern ich brauche das Video
nicht mehr im Hintergrund, ich brauche das Video nicht mehr im Hintergrund,
ich brauche das Video nicht mehr im Hintergrund,
dann brauche ich mich nicht mehr im Hintergrund,
Gameplay zu kümmern.
Okay, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Use und demonstrate it. Okay.
Okay, okay.
Und einfach type in winget, das ist der Befehl.
Und wenn du es mit nichts anderes type,
kann es dir ein paar Beispiele von Befehlern zeigen,
die du benutzen kannst. Also, sagen wir,
Notepad++, das ist ein Programm, das ich benutze.
Du kannst type in winget, suche
Notepad++.
Und es wird einfach
suchen für irgendwelche Packages, die mit dem Namen
sind. Und du kannst sehen, dass es hoch ist.
Also, weißt du das Name von dem,
wenn du es aufhast,
kann ich einfach type in winget, install,
Notepad++,
und es würde dann nachdenken und installieren.
Und wenn es eine neue Version gibt,
kannst du einfach type in winget, upgrade
und dann das Name des Programms,
oder du kannst eigentlich type in winget, upgrade,
dash, dash, all,
und es würde dann nachdenken und installieren,
und es würde dann nachdenken und upgrade
alles, was ein Update gibt.
Außerdem, so lang
dauert es jetzt auch nicht.
Guck mal hier,
notepad, code,
bam.
Also kann mir jetzt keiner erzählen, dass es so
krass lang gedauert hat, obwohl das auch so
viel Zeug geladen hat.
Also, ewig, ewig starten
ist jetzt ja nur wirklich was anderes.
Ja.
Ich meine, das hat immer, das hat, das hat,
ups, nicht note,
code.
Und es geht dann noch schneller auf, wenn man es schon mal
offen hatte. Also,
so viel schneller ist jetzt
notepad++ auch nicht.
Notepad, habe ich notepad++ drauf?
Also ich meine, ich kenne, ich kenne das Argument,
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
das Zeug ist mittlerweile so schnell, dass es
eigentlich nicht mehr, nicht mehr zieht.
Es braucht länger als notepad++.
Ja, aber warum sollte ich zwei Sachen
drauf machen? Die 10,
die, die, die 10 Millisekunden
da, ich meine jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Also.
Das ist jetzt,
das ist jetzt wirklich kein großartiges Problem,
Alter. Und ich habe noch ein paar, das Ding
muss so viele Tabs laden und noch
plugins, ja.
Aber ich meine, ihr könnt ja installieren,
was ihr wollt. Aber gerade für Notizen
würde ich eh ein extra Notes-Programm verwenden
und, oder halten Visual Studio Code permanent
offen haben.
Ja, okay.
Kuren Bugs.
Das probieren wir aus, das probieren wir aus,
das probieren wir aus im Stream.
Ja, ich habe es mir schon aufgeschrieben,
WinGet. Ich wette mit euch, ich finde
innerhalb der ersten fünf Minuten Sachen, die nicht ordentlich
funktionieren.
Aber Max, warum hast du den Windows-Editor
verwendet und nicht Visual Studio Code? Weil ich nicht dran gedacht
habe, dass ich Visual Studio Code installiert habe.
Hier. Weil es ist, es geht halt
standardmäßig auf. Aber ich könnte das
genauso gut verknüpfen mit, wo
ist es denn? Hier, da. Guck mal,
das steht da gar nicht drinne. Es ist einfach nicht
drinne. Es würde überhaupt nichts dagegen sprechen.
Außerdem ist ja die Frage
nicht ob Notepad
oder Visual Studio Code, sondern die Frage
ist Notepad++ oder Visual Studio Code.
Und da sehe ich halt den Sinn,
ich drinnen zwei Sachen zu installieren
anstatt eine, die ich
für alles verwenden kann.
Egal, das kann jeder verwenden, was er will.
Das gucken wir uns dem Stream dann mal an.
Developers, Developers, Developers.
Ja, ja.
Wenn Microsoft later was fixen will, dann wissen wir, was da rauskommt.
Ob Apple auch bald einen eigenen Package Manager macht,
haben sie ja mit ihrem App Store. Im Endeffekt schon.
Lässt sich vielleicht nicht so cool bedienen,
aber bei Apple gibt es das ja schon eine Weile,
wenn man den App Store als Package Manager durchgehen lässt.
Was er aber im Prinzip ja
ist, ist es ja eigentlich.
Specky, was ist Specky?
Anzeige ist aus.
Ja gut, das ist halt die Sache von einem Package Manager.
Alternativ gibt es, je nach Package Manager,
den man sich anguckt, selbstverständlich die Möglichkeit,
neue Versionen zu installieren.
Es ist jetzt egal, ob man sich mal was weiß ich,
Jam anguckt, NPM anguckt, Cargo anguckt, was auch immer.
Was gibt es auch noch so für Package Manager?
Die meisten Package Manager für Libraries und sowas
können alte Versionen installieren.
Wohingegen sich Package Manager, die sich eben um Betriebssystemseite
und Programme kümmern, die legen oftmals Wert darauf,
dass man halt die aktuellste Version installiert.
Ich glaube, es gibt für Pacman, bin ich mir gar nicht sicher,
ehrlich gesagt, gibt es für Pacman ein Kommando,
dass man alte Sachen installiert?
Doch muss es geben, gibt es, gibt es.
Weil man kann, man kann downgrade machen, ein Package.
Also das muss, das muss prinzipiell funktionieren.
Ja, guck.
Ist das eben ein PowerShell-Crap?
WinGet?
Oder ist das was Ordentliches?
Ok, dash all ist anscheinend verbugt.
Ok, im Prinzip erfährt man da jetzt nicht wirklich viel in dem Video.
Mich würde mal interessieren, uninstall,
ob das mittlerweile gescheit funktioniert.
Angeblich ja, praktisch gibt es da wohl Probleme mit.
Ja, anscheinend gibt es damit Probleme.
Test es doch mal in der VR, mach ich auch, aber nicht jetzt im Stream.
Dann mach ich mal einen Stream für.
Anzeige, direkt Abmahnung an Microsoft.
Was?
Was ist das für ein Feature-Request?
Product New Cryptocurrency.
Ist das, ist das, ist das Github-Spam?
Ist das wirklich Github, Github, äh, der nigerianische Prinz quasi auf Github?
Das ist, ich hab das noch nie gesehen, dass es, dass es Github-Spam gibt.
Cool, nice.
Was bedeutet denn Needs Triage?
Ausprobieren oder was?
Ausschuss bei Kaffeebohnen.
Was ist, Alter, was ist Triage?
Was ist das?
Die Auswahl, Sichtung, Sichtung, ah, Sichtung, okay, das ergibt sich.
Sprich, muss mal einer drüber gucken, muss ich mal einer angucken.
Ich, ich lass mich gern eines Besseren belehren, wenn sich das durchsetzt, aber ich kann's mir bei Microsoft und den Sachen in der Richtung einfach nicht vorstellen.
Ist das, ist das funktioniert?
Er sieht man, was da schon drinne ist?
Install Microsoft Windows Terminal.
Oh, guck mal hier.
Poggers Progress Bar, Alter, Massive.
Ja, das probieren wir mal im nächsten Stream aus.
RGB, RGB Installer, sehr nice.
So, Far Cry 6 könnte genau das sein, was Fans sich seit Jahren wünschen.
Komm, da gucken wir uns jetzt eine Runde Far Cry 6 an.
Ich fand ja dieses experimentelle Zeug mit den Waffen jetzt nicht so geil, ehrlich gesagt.
Wo sie vorhin gezeigt haben, dass man mit CDs Leute anschießt und so.
Ich fand da eigentlich so das Waffen Arsenal so in Far Cry 4 und 3 ganz cool, dass das noch Waffen waren, halt realistische.
Man muss ja nicht auf Teufel kommen raus, irgendwelche Crafting Sachen da einbauen, nur weil es geht.
Aber letztendlich ist es Ubisoft.
Also Ubisoft macht ja im Prinzip eh immer das gleiche Game.
Nur halt mit anderer Kameraperspektive.
Es ist immer der gleiche Kram aus Camps Aussicht, Punkten und Crafting.
Oh, guck mal. War eine ordentliche AK.
Es wird kein Gericht, das ihr noch nie gegessen habt.
Keine völlig unbekannte neue Cuisine-Kreation.
Sondern genau die Art fettige Wonne, auf die ihr nachts um 2 Uhr im Burger-Laden so richtig Bock habt.
Was ein Intro, Alter.
Alles gut.
Vyros, BLN, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, das muss ich erstmal zeigen, ob der Bösewicht so geil ist.
Äh, warte mal, wie war das mit Lebensenergie in Far Cry 3?
Doch, in Far Cry 3 hatte man Lebensenergie.
Da hatte man unten diese Balken und konnte sich dann selbst heilen mit diesen Spritzen und Verbänden und so.
Das war doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Far Cry 6 wird einfach nur ehrliche Open-World-Shooter-Action sein.
Ich zeige euch jetzt, warum ich das richtig, richtig gut finde.
Diese Eindrücke hier basieren auf einer knapp 20-minütigen Gameplay-Präsentation von Ubisoft und den Clips, die ihr hier im Hintergrund seht.
Wir konnten Far Cry 6 also noch nicht selbst spielen.
Ach, bei den Gegnern?
Es geht hier in erster Linie um die ersten Eindrücke.
Wartet mit den Vorbestellungen also lieber noch, bis es...
Vorbestellen?
Vorbestellen ist das Dümste, was man machen kann.
Der einzige Grund vorzubestellen ist, wenn man vielleicht irgendwie eine Collector's Edition haben will, weil man sich...
Weil da irgendein Stato dabei ist, die man sich ins Schrank stellen will.
Deswegen, okay, verstehe ich. Aber solange es um rein digitale Sachen geht, ist Vorbestellen total unsinnig.
Wozu? Was ist der Sinn?
Man kann den Kram eh erst zum Release-Zeitpunkt spielen.
Eh, immer.
Das heißt, ich kann auch erst mal abwarten.
Never pre-order, genau.
Also, was wird Far Cry 6 für ein Spiel?
Die Rahmenbedingungen von Far Cry 6 waren uns schon vor der Gameplay-Präsentation bekannt.
In der überhaupt nicht mit Kuba zu verwechseln...
Da haben sich ja vermutet die Leute, dass das was ist in Jung.
Aber ist es nicht.
Im Blick Jahre müsst ihr als wahlweise männlicher oder weiblicher Revoluzzer Danny das korrupte Regime von Diktator Anton Castillo zu Fall bringen.
Und in der Far Cry Welt heißt das stets das Gleiche.
Ihr müsst die gesamte Open World für euch und eure revolutionären Gefährten erobern.
Die altbewährte Far Cry-Formel bleibt also erhalten.
Danny infiltriert in Ego-Perspektive entweder laut oder leise, feindliche Außenposten, bahnt sich einen Weg durch die Natur,
experimentiert mit allerlei bekannten, aber auch kuriosen Waffen, um im Finale dem charismatischen Bösewicht die Stirn zu bieten.
Was wir bisher von der Open World gesehen haben, haut mich ziemlich aus den Armee-Stiefeln.
Jahre hat das Zeug die bisher abwechslungsreichste Far Cry Welt zu werden.
Diesmal gibt es mit dem überhaupt nicht mit Havanna zu verwechselnden Esperanza eine richtige Stadt.
Außerdem Dschungel, Strände, Sümpfe, Berglandschaften, kleinere Dörfer, alte Festungen.
Stimmt, Far Cry 3 gab es keine Städte.
Es gab so kleine Dörfchen.
Und, und, und.
Auch wenn das hier anders aussehen mag, die ganze Turnalität der Gameplay-Präsentation geht dabei eher ins Abgedrehte.
Far Cry 6 erzählt zwar durchaus eine ernste, brutale Widerstandsgeschichte,
vergisst aber nicht, dass es in erster Linie ein spaßiger Shooter sein will.
Die Nebenfiguren wirken genau so schrill und überzeichnet,
wie sie es in einer Welt sein müssten, in der ich Krodi-Gefährten an meine Seite rufe
und CD-Stapel zu tödlichen Sägeblattwerfern umfunktioniert habe.
Ja, das verstehe ich, na egal.
Die Waffen, dass es so, dieses Waffencrafting ist, das spricht mich jetzt nicht so an.
Denn damit wären wir schon bei den großen Neuerungen von Far Cry 6.
Far Cry 6 verlässt sich zwar auf altbekannte Tugenden, wagt aber natürlich auch einige frische Experimente.
Eines davon ist die sogenannte Resolver-Philosophie.
Die was?
Bei Yara, seit Jahrzehnten von der Außenwelt abgeschottet existiert, gibt's in der Inselrepublik kaum moderne Technologie.
Eine ganze Generation armer Seelen wächst hier ohne Instagram und TikTok auf.
Doch das befeuert nur den Ehrgeiz der Bevölkerung mit allerlei Retro-Gadgets, wilde Eigenkreationen zusammenzuschrauben.
Viele Waffen und Gegenstände im Spiel bestehen aus kuriosem Schott.
Danny schraubte Büchsen als Schalldämpfer auf die Pistole, benutzt alte Silvesterböller, um Hubschrauber vom Himmel zu holen
und funktioniert besagt...
Aha, Moment, die haben, die haben nichts, die haben nichts, aber Hubschrauber haben sie, oder wie?
...mit einem südlichen Sägeblattwerfer um, der zwischen den Schüssen lautstark Makarena dudelt.
Mit dieser Schrauber-Metallik könnt ihr alles im Spiel frei anpassen und kombinieren.
Waffen, Autos und Dannys Outfits.
Wie elegant diese ganzen Freischaltungen ins Spiel integriert werden, weiß ich aktuell noch nicht,
aber an viele Gegenstände sind Perks gekoppelt.
Ziehen wir Danny eine Scharfschützenbrille an, erhält er oder sie...
Der Makarena zieht die Lautschal...
Okay, die Idee ist nice.
Total beknackt, aber irgendwie ist es nice.
Vorurteile bei Präzisionsschüssen.
Im schlimmsten Fall wartet hier ein kleinteiliger Lootgrind auf uns.
Im besten Fall passe ich mit herrlich vielen Möglichkeiten mein Vorgehen an.
Einen Hoffnungsschimmer gibt es hier.
Nach eigenen Angaben soll das Lootsystem ganz anders funktionieren als noch bei Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
Gegner lassen kann...
Ja, Gott sei Dank, Alter.
Gehst mal fort mit Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
Ich weiß, ich habe selbst ein Video zugemacht, aber ich habe nur ein Video zugemacht, weil ich Geld dafür gekriegt habe.
Ihr findet zwar Gegenstände in der Spielwelt.
Far Cry 6 soll aber ganz ausdrücklich kein Lootshooter werden.
Im Spiel wird es mehr als 49 frei anpassbare Waffen geben.
Darunter eben exotische Resolverkreationen, aber auch eher Handelsübungen.
In your face, jawoll.
Sniper Rifles, Sturmgewehre, Pistolen, Flammen, Granate.
Du musst da noch ein Smiley dranhängen, dann wird es fast aussehen wie die Bad Company 2 Granate.
Außerdem sogenannte Supremos Waffen.
Ihr könnt euch beispielsweise Raketenrohre auf den Rücken schnallen und dann wie Boba Fett einen Heli damit vom Himmel holen.
Na klar.
Wie in echt.
Ihr müsst Far Cry 6 aber nicht zwangsläufig wie einen karibischen Rage 2 Verschnitt spielen.
Alternativ nehmt ihr ganz bogen...
Ah, Bogen. Ohne Bogen geht nichts in einem Far Cry.
... und pirscht wie Rambo durch den Dschungel.
Das geht im Zweifelsfall immer.
Also auch im Spiel.
Neben dem Resolver Prinzip gibt es noch weitere Neuerungen.
Zum Beispiel mehr Fahrzeuge.
Danny verlässt sich auf Autos, Boote, Flugzeuge, Helikopter, Pferde und Panzer.
Ebenfalls neu ist Social Stealth.
Regimesoldaten ballern euch nicht in jedem Fall direkt über den Haufen.
Wenn Danny alle Waffen wegsteckt, könnt ihr euch an vielen Orten frei bewegen, solange ihr kein Aufsehen erregt.
Das erinnert an Assassin's Creed, wo das Feature zuletzt in Valhalla wieder zum Einsatz kam.
Außerdem könnt ihr eure Spielfigur jetzt richtig sehen.
In den Gerea-Camps holt ihr euch nicht nur neue Missionen, sondern steuert Danny nach Wunsch-Aus-Third-Person-Ansicht.
So seht ihr euer Outfit wenigstens mal.
Danny ist auch nicht stumm.
Anders als in Far Cry 5 spielt ihr in Teil 6 kein...
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ich bin...
Diese ganze Skin-Geschichte juckt mich ja in Singleplayer-Spielen jetzt immer recht wenig.
Ich will Action-Shooter-Stealths.
Aber okay, warum nicht?
...eine stumme Hauptfigur.
Danny ist eine konkrete Person mit eigener Hintergrundgeschichte, die fleißig mitplaudert.
Zwischen Sequenzen finden also nicht mehr nur in der Ego-Ansicht statt.
Und ich muss Esperanza hier noch mehr hervorheben, denn die Far Cry-Serie bekommt erstmals eine richtige Stadt,
in der ihr euch auch auf Dächern verschanzen, in Gebäuden verstecken und auf offener Straße bekriegen könnt.
Und, äh, wichtige Neuerung Nummer 6. Das Erobern von feindlichen Festungen wird ausgebaut.
Ich infiltriere im Spiel gigantische Einrichtungen, um Flaggstellungen zu zerstören,
den Rebellen einen neuen Unterschlupf zu erobern und und und.
Auch Verschleiß gibt es jetzt. Euer Schalldämpfer geht nach zu viel Gebrauch kaputt,
weil es sich dabei nur um eine Büchse handelt.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da so ein Fan von bin, von Ausrüstung kaputt.
Das geht mir schon viel zu sehr in Richtung, ich muss die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Nachschubdinger aufsammeln,
und und Crafting-Gedöns machen. Ich finde Far Cry 3 hatte da echt eine ganz gute Mischung.
Du musstest am Anfang ein paar, ein paar Tiere fangen und dir ein paar, äh, Beutel basteln für, äh, mehr Munition,
und ein paar Beutel basteln für mehr Leben, aber das war's zum größten Teil.
Du konntest in Far Cry 1, hast du im ersten Drittel dir so ein bisschen Sachen noch zusammengecraftet,
was ja auch ganz cool war, du bist ja auf der Insel quasi gestrandet und so,
und danach ging's aber gradlinig weiter, ab und zu mal ein bisschen geupgraded und gut ist.
Ja, weiß nicht, ob, naja, mal gucken, mal gucken, wie sie's machen.
Okay, da weißt du genau, was sie da mit ansprechen wollen.
Moment.
Okay, wenn ich die Auswahl hab zwischen Krokodil und dem Hund, dann würd ich sogar eher den Hund nehmen.
So ein Krokodil ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so das Niedlichste.
So, bei den Gegnertypen bleibt Far Cry 6 anscheinend sehr klassisch.
Es gibt reguläre Soldaten, außerdem schwergepanzerte Spezialisten, die Schilde vor sich auf dem Boden rammen.
Aber imhin rücken die Gegner jetzt mit Panzern an, was euch natürlich für neue taktische Herausforderungen stellt.
Ganz grundsätzlich wird Far Cry 6 die Serie nicht neu erfinden, das hab ich ja schon gesagt.
Auch technisch wirkt das Spiel bisher zwar in seinen Landschaften äußerst hübsch, wenn man dann aber an manchen Stellen genauer hin...
Okay, das sieht genauso aus, wie ich mir vor Far Cry gedacht hätte.
... sieht man schon, dass das Ding auch auf einer PS4 und Xbox One laufen muss.
Aber das muss ja überhaupt kein Problem sein.
Wir sehen in Far Cry 6 das Potential für einen richtig, richtig guten Open-World-Shooter, der die Stärken der Serie weiter ausarbeitet.
Okay, die NPCs sind immer noch so dumm wie je und je.
Ich mein, was würdest du machen, wenn dein Kollege neben dir gesniped wird?
Würdest du sagen, ha, ist da jemand?
Und in eine Richtung gucken, natürlich.
Oder realistisch betrachtet würde er hinter die Sandsäcke in Deckung hüpfen oder abhauen oder irgendwo.
Und nicht, ha, ist da jemand?
Ha, es war nur der Wind.
Erstens, wie wird das Loot-System? Ubisoft hat bereits in Assassin's Creed Valhalla sehr viele gelernte Lektionen umgesetzt und eine sehr ausbalancierte Beutejagd an den Start gebracht.
Setzt Far Cry 6 diesen Trend fort oder wird die Jagd nach neuen Bauteilen, T-Shirts und Fahrzeug aufsetzen mit der Zeit ein bisschen zu stumpfsinnig?
Frage Nummer 2, wurde das Gunplay verbessert?
Einer meiner größten Kritikpunkte an Far Cry 5 war das ziemlich mauere Trefferfeedback, dass der Konkurrenz merklich hinterherhinkt.
Aktuell kann ich noch nicht gut einschätzen, wie sich die Schießereien in Far Cry 6 anfühlen.
Aber es sieht nicht ganz wuchtig aus.
Und die dritte Frage, wie wird der Koop?
Far Cry 6 bekommt wieder einen Zwei-Spieler-Koop, das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Aber ich weiß noch nicht, ob der endlich sein größtes Problem los wird, dass der Fortschritt bisher immer nur für Spieler 1 gespeichert wurde.
So, Zeit also für ein Fazit.
Die absolut wichtigste Verbesserung, die Far Cry 6 für mich persönlich umsetzt, es wirkt kohärent.
Gut, Kohärenz ist jetzt keines der fünf sexy Marketing-Fachwörter.
Aber es war die eine Sache, die Far Cry 5 für mich immer wieder ausgebreitet hat.
Das haben die nicht mitge- Okay, die NPCs sind typisch Ubisoft-dumm-NPCs.
Aber das ist ja bei allen solchen Schleich-Stells-Games.
... worauf sie hinausfüllen, ein Open-World-Flow, der immer wieder dadurch unterbrochen wurde, dass meine Spielfigur für Zwischensequenzen bewusstlos wird.
Eine ominöse Sekten-Schurken-Fraktion, die man nie komplett verstanden hat, weil alles immer vage und unkonkret blieb.
Far Cry 6 räumt hier, und zumindest wirkt es bisher so, radikal auf.
Denn das Spiel gibt mir eine sehr klare Mission.
Ein böser Diktator beherrscht eine-
Gut, das ist ja Far Cry Standard.
... und kleiner Hund, mach was draus.
Ubisoft-Spiele sind immer dann am besten, wenn ich mich ungehindert der Open-World-Action hingeben kann.
Ich kann die Strecke in den Dschungel meiner eigenen Routen infiltrieren.
Schauen, ob ich auf diesen Berg am Horizont hoch kann, mit dem Flugzeug die Landschaft aufsaugen...
Hübsch sieht das aus.
Das könnte auch der Battlefield 6-Trailer sein, an der Stelle.
Ich würde auch durchgehen.
... und und und.
Damit bietet Far Cry 6 ein sehr ähnliches Paket wie zuletzt Far Cry 4.
Allerdings mit deutlich größerer, vielseitigerer Open-World samt echter Stadt.
Und das ist ein Deal, auf den ich extrem viel Bock habe.
Sofern sich das Ganze am Ende auch gut stabiliert.
Also das ist durchaus ein Game, wo ich drüber nachgedacht habe, ob ich mir das hole.
Aber ich werde es nicht vorbestellen.
Wie gesagt, Vorbestellen ist bescheuert. Vorbestellen ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wichtigste Frage überhaupt zu dem Game.
Tja, wir werden es erst erfahren, wenn es raus ist.
Wobei stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Wenn der Protagonist männlich und weiblich ist, dann müsste sich das ja...
Wobei.
Wobei in der heutigen Zeit ist das ja auch alles kein Ding.
Da geht ja alles mit allem irgendwie.
Dann müssen sich da doch nicht mehr so viele Gedanken drüber machen.
Wobei ich ja das Ende von Far Cry 3 schon ein bisschen überraschend fand.
Dass es die Alte damit hier treibt und dich dann ersticht.
Das hat mich damals schon ein bisschen geschockt.
Hab ich gesagt, oh, die meinen es echt ernst.
Okay, es gab ja zwei Enden in Far Cry 3.
Es gab ja das Ende, wo man seine Freundin rettet und abhaut.
Und es gab das Ende, was ich gerade beschrieben habe.
Spoiler.
Nein.
Leute, ich habe ein Game gespoilert von 2013 oder so.
Ich habe ein Game gespoilert von 2012.
Community Strike ist raus.
Report ist weg, ja.
Nice.
GG Eats.
Der was?
Der Full-Stack-Development-Iceberg-Shorts.
39 Sekunden, okay, können wir uns angucken.
Guck mal, mein eigenes Video.
Interesting, alles klar.
Okay, das letzte Slash-Resistant, was er auf seinem Channel gezeigt hat, war absolut nicht Slash-Resistant.
Gucken wir mal, ob das Slash-Resistant ist.
Ich tippe mal auf Nein, das ist nicht Slash-Resistant.
This is the Lockpicking Lawyer and what I have for you today is a Locktoad brand anti-theft bag, which I picked up on Amazon for $69. $69, guter Preis.
Holding this closed is a nylon strap with two embedded steel cables, as well as a couple of grommets, through which you can pass the shackle of a padlock.
Ja, also dieses Schloss ist ja für ihn nix. Das macht er nachts, wenn er mal aufs Klo muss, nebenbei auf.
Nee, ist es nicht. Spoiler, spoiler, ist es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Those of you who watch regularly have probably guessed that this caught my eye due to a Slash-Resistant marketing claim.
Zeig mal her.
The Amazon listing says it's quote, one piece design, 100% constructed with Slash-Resistant materials.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
We're gonna put that to the test today using my Everyday Carry Pocketknife.
Der nimmt das jetzt, schneidet durch und es ist auf.
Let's give it a try.
Das ist auch geil, dieses Slash-Resistant-Dinger.
Huge Slash-Resistant.
Da ist, vor allem, da ist überhaupt nix drin, da ist überhaupt nix drin, was irgendwie Slash-Resistant sein könnte.
So, that seems to be about par for the course, at least with what I've seen on the market.
I'll probably continue testing a few more of these.
Ist das nicht eigentlich verboten?
Ich mein, du verkaufst ja hier im Endeffekt was, was überhaupt nicht der Realität anspricht und im Zweifelsfall auch gefährlich ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, irgendjemand zieht sich das an, meint es ist Slash-Resistant, schnallt sich ins Bein.
Da kannst du bei der Amis, kannst du den bestimmt verklagen auf 50 Millionen.
I'm not expecting much.
In any case, that's all I have for you today.
If you do have any questions or comments about this, please put them below.
If you liked this video and would like to see more like it, please subscribe.
Das war klar, das war klar, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Unbreakable, unpickable, okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt kurz angucken.
This is the Lockpicking Lawyer and I recently received a package from Ted Tooling, a company in Nevada,
which sells this $400 hidden shackle padlock.
This is the key to it and it's billed as unbreakable, unpickable and even bulletproof.
Okay, Spoiler, es ist nicht unpickable, so wie ich den Kerl kenn, sonst würde er wahrscheinlich das Video nicht machen.
Pretty bold claims, but this is also a really unusual lock.
As for the claims regarding physical toughness, while nothing is truly unbreakable,
I'm convinced it would take an act of extraordinary violence to break.
It's almost certainly tougher than whatever you are locking.
As for the pick-proof claim, it's not something easy to discuss without showing you how it works.
Was, Discord-Notification ist erst jetzt, ernsthaft? So ein bisschen langsam?
Bulletproof, ne, das muss es sein, das ist Kokona Zeug, das muss bulletproof sein.
Das ist richtig, jetzt advanced, das Ding.
Indirect, opposite of the hot coals.
Sagen Sie doch bei den Barbecue Pit Boys immer, in jedem Video.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt auf Pepo-Fett essen komme, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt kommt Big Brain.
Was ist das für eine Zange, das ist ja...
Huge Zange.
Pausechamp, wetten, wetten, das wird jetzt gleich funktionieren.
Magnet.
Das hat er sich gedacht, das lässt er jetzt bleiben, weil das wahrscheinlich ziemlich schwer abzukriegen ist.
Das ist der Schloss auf hebende Rechtsanwalt, genau.
Easy as fuck, easy as fuck.
Easy as fuck.
Woher hast du den Easy as fuck Sound, den habe ich aus irgendeiner koreanischen Text-to-Speech-Engine.
Ja, das war klar, dass das easy aufgeht.
Hast du den irgendwo zum Download?
Nope, habe ich nicht.
Kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe im Chat.
Okay, sieht nicht so aus.
Und vor allem 400 Dollar für ein Schloss, ich meine 400 Dollar musst du euch mal überlegen, was ist da los.
Das ist ja, da kriegst du ja schon 50 andere Schlösser quasi für...
Oh, guck mal, der Endpunkt ist da, excellent.
Huge, glaube ich zumindest.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher vom Namen her, könnte sein.
Ist das Chromium? Ja, das ist Chromium, das ist angugelt.
Schau in Discord, Moment.
Ja, okay, er ist es.
Nice.
Ich check nicht, wie das Schloss was abschließt.
Ja, ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Das riesige Netzwerk der Instagram Betrüger.
Okay, das ist wieder total auf dramatisch gemacht.
Die Videos sind immer so auf mega dramatisch gemacht.
Was baut der PS5-Case?
Okay, wir cringen jetzt ein bisschen durch dramatisches Simplicissimus-Video.
Das hier ist die zweite Version dieses Videos.
Wir haben uns nach neuen Erkenntnissen zu einer Bearbeitung und einem Reupload entschlossen.
Okay, also habt ihr verkackt sozusagen.
Was würdet ihr machen, wenn ihr mehrere Millionen Follower auf Insta hättet?
Vielleicht ein bisschen Werbung für dieses oder jenes Produkt?
Vielleicht ein E-Book oder etwas Merch?
Falsch.
Diese 21 Seiten zeigen, wie es geht.
Sie bewerben eine Reihe an Telegram-Kanälen randvoll mit gestohlenen Nacktbildern.
In diesen Kanälen wird dann wiederum eine angebliche Person beworben,
die pornografische Inhalte von sich vertickt.
Gut, ihre Identität und ihr Material sind ebenfalls gestohlen.
Aber so kann man an einzelnen Tagen weit über 1.000 Euro einsacken.
Moment, für was genau donaten die Leute?
Hä, das hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Warum donaten die Leute da welche?
Für was?
Dass sie Zugriff auf die Fotos bekommen oder wie?
Für die Bilder.
Warum donatet einer 50 Euro im Internet für Porn, Alter?
Sind die total hängen geblieben alle?
Blöd nur, dass jemand diesen schönen, groß angelegten Scam
über Wochen hinweg beobachtet, dokumentiert und analysiert hat.
Es wird mal wieder Zeit.
Alter, jetzt übertreib mal nicht mit der Musik.
Der macht da jetzt aber Attacke.
Eine Güte.
Am Anfang des Scams stehen mindestens 21 Instagram-Seiten.
Warum nicht 69?
Pollen-Sex-Fakten und lustigen Tattoos ist alles dabei.
Über Wochen hinweg haben diese Seiten
verschiedene zusammengehörige Telegram-Kanäle beworben.
Sind wir auf Pro7 gelandet?
So ähnlich, ne?
Das ist immer so auf super dramatisch gemacht, der Kram.
Und immer wieder durch verschiedene Links in der Beschreibung.
Mindestens diese Accounts sind beteiligt.
Ja, okay, Scam-Links verteilen im Internet
ist jetzt ja nun wirklich nichts Neues.
Kennt noch jemand Liebesakt-Fakten?
Ernsthaft? Es hat jemand seinen Kanal Liebesakt-Fakten genannt.
Na gut, Instagram halt.
Ich mein, Scam-Links zu verschicken,
war ja früher auch schon immer Hobby von den Leuten.
Kennt noch jemand das Penner-Game?
Oder diese Spiele mit nach dem Motto,
dir wurden 50 Credits geklaut, weil du auf den Link gegangen bist.
Melde dich jetzt hier auch an und klaue Leute 50 Credits.
Lustige Zettel, erlaubt vor 18, schmutzige Storys, Horror-Date-Storys.
Schmutzige Storys, ja, alles natürlich.
Da siehst du mal, wie degeneriert teilweise die Leute mittlerweile sind,
um den Scheiß nicht anzugucken, Alter.
Work-Storys, Horror-Familien-Storys.
Oh, das ist ein Crap.
Doktorspiel-Fakten, Jungs-Fakten, Geschlechts-Fakten.
Doktorspiel-Fakten, Geschlechts-Fakten.
Jungs-Fakten, Google-Antworten.
Es gibt einen Instagram-Account, der Google-Ergebnisse postet.
Jungs-Fakten, Geschlechts-Fakten, Google-Antworten.
Zwei deutige Memes, wasted Moments, blau gesoffen,
Tageshoroskop, Namensbedeutungen, FML-Momente und Konterchats.
Das macht theoretisch insgesamt rund 7,2 Millionen Follower.
Sicherlich überschneidet sich da einiges,
dennoch eine beachtliche Reichweite.
Die Seiten lassen sich durch verschiedene Indizien in vier Gruppen einteilen.
Das ist quasi Ctrl-C, Ctrl-V von Reddit, ja, im Endeffekt.
Im Endeffekt ist so was zu bauen wahrscheinlich relativ einfach.
Du nimmst irgendeinen Crawler für Reddit, 4chan, Program und sonstige Dinge
und lädst einfach random auf diesen Channels da Sachen hoch.
Kann sich ja auch wiederholen, juckt auch nicht großartig.
Geschlechts-Fakten immer noch am besten. Nee, Liebesakt-Fakten.
Das ist ein scheiß Name für den Instagram-Account.
Zum einen die So-und-So-Stories.
Insgesamt sind das acht Seiten, die sich alle gegenseitig folgen,
verlinken und die gleiche Aufmachung haben.
Mindestens vier der Seiten sind an dem mutmaßlichen Scam beteiligt.
Sechs weitere Pages laufen über dieselbe Web.de-E-Mail-Adresse.
Sechs andere laufen über eine GMX-E-Mail.
Dazu kommen drei Accounts einer GmbH in Bayern.
Diese Firma verwaltet augenscheinlich noch zahlreiche weitere Pages.
Eine mögliche Beteiligung am mutmaßlichen Scam ist hier aber jeweils unklar.
Die Leute wollen doch gescampt werden, die sich so was angucken, oder?
Es handelt sich um ein riesiges Netzwerk aus Instagram-Seiten.
Aber obwohl es derart viele Accounts sind,
deutet einiges auf nur wenige zentrale Verantwortliche hin.
Die Frage ist halt, bis jetzt ist daran ja nix illegal, oder?
Blöde Bildchen hochladen, außer vielleicht das Copyright für die Bilder.
Aber ansonsten...
Es ist ja nicht verboten, Scheiße zu verkaufen, ne?
Jungsfakten erlaubt vor 18 die Themen, die A zu schreiben,
die Personen, die sich in den Kommentaren tummeln.
Viele der Seiten richten sich ziemlich eindeutig an ein jugendliches...
Was denn sonst?
An dieses Publikum...
... gibt das Netzwerk einen Ring aus sieben öffentlichen Kanälen
im Messenger Telegram.
Besonders zwei Kanäle werden beworben.
Wir nennen sie im Folgenden Xfrauen und TikTokX.
Ersterer hat rund 60.000 Follower, zweiterer knapp 50.000.
In den Kanälen werden pornografische Inhalte veröffentlicht.
In der Beschreibung des Xfrauen-Kanals heißt es,
man sei gegen Kinderpornografie und würde rechtlich dagegen vorgehen.
Na, immerhin etwas.
Aber das reicht natürlich nicht.
Telegram ist in Deutschland im App-Store ab 17.
Im Play Store wird die Altersfreigabe der USK ab 18 angezeigt.
Egal, es juckt das irgendjemand.
Es ist aber rechtlich irrelevant,
wenn irgendwelche Leute pornografische Bilder
über Telegram verbreiten.
Dann greifen ganz andere Normen.
Dann greifen Jugendschutznormen.
Der Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag greift dort.
Der jimst...
Der Bundesgerichtshof hat auch so schon ausgeurteilt,
dass man geschlossene Benutzergruppen haben muss,
wenn man pornografische Bilder verbreiten möchte.
Das ist Christian Solmecke
von der Medienrechtskanzlei Wilde Beuger Solmecke.
Er hat uns erklärt, dass Telegram-Kanäle
eben keine solchen geschlossenen Benutzergruppen sind.
Tja, und bei einem Verstoß gegen den Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag...
Ja, und?
Dann droht eine Freiheitsstrafe von...
Als interessiert das die Plattform in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ja, weil hier Inhalte öffentlich zugänglich gemacht worden sind,
die ganz offensichtlich dazu geeignet sind,
die Entwicklung von Kindern zu gefährden.
Nach Solmeckes Einschätzung ist potenziell sogar schon
das öffentliche Verlinken dieser Telegram-Kanäle
auf Instagram illegal.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Müsste da nicht auch das öffentliche Verlinken
auf OnlyFans illegal sein?
Das heißt, die ganzen Hothoop-Grills
könnten ihre Instagram-Accounts nicht mal verlinken.
Das ist so...
Ja, natürlich ist das alles geklaut.
Wo soll denn das sonst herkommen?
Okay, das ist natürlich definitiv nicht erlaubt.
Ja, gut, dass das nicht erlaubt ist, klar.
Ich sehe die ganze Zeit die Jahre Haft drauf,
wenn man die Hintermänner packt im Höchstmaß.
Wenn das nur vereinzelt gemacht worden ist,
würde man auch mit einer Geldstrafe hinkommen.
Ich sehe es aber hier so.
Das Ausmaß ist so massiv und so groß,
dass man ohne Haftstrafe da nicht mehr rauskommen wird.
Gestohlene Bilder mit meine Ex Lea 21 zu inszenieren,
ist ganz unabhängig davon schon ziemlich, na ja, ekelhaft.
Ja, gut, das interessiert die Betreiber ja nicht.
Die Absicht dahinter.
By the way, das ist aber eigentlich auch...
Dieser Scam in der Richtung ist ja eigentlich auch schon so alt wie das Internet.
Es gab doch früher auch schon immer irgendwelche Seiten,
wo sie dich drauf gelockt haben,
und da stand dann irgendwie, was weiß ich,
wenn das bis zum 15.06. so und so viele Likes hat,
dann postet Julia irgendwelche Nacktbilder oder so.
Das ist doch schon der Klassiker.
Und Spoiler, hat sie nie gemacht.
Ja, natürlich.
Tja.
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht?
300 Euro, also ein Schnapper.
Warum sollten...
Also es machen ja anscheinend Leute,
aber warum um alles in der Welt sollte man sich im Internet
300 Euro für einen Pornbilder-Tipp ausgeben?
Warum? Es gibt so viel Zeug im Internet.
Warum sollte man das machen? Ich verstehe das nicht.
Was?
Also haben wir uns an ein paar schönen Abenden Ende März
einfach mal dazugesetzt und das Geld gezählt,
das die Leute so an Lisa für ein Videopaket abdrücken.
Das hier sind natürlich nicht alle Einnahmen,
weil nicht jeder Käufer in den Listen auftaucht.
Aber sie geben einen Überblick.
Manche Menschen haben in diesem Fall über 60 Euro an Lisa gespendet,
vielleicht in der Hoffnung, privat mit ihr in Kontakt zu kommen.
Ja gut, die Leute sind eh komplett lost.
Die Leute sind eh komplett lost.
Das ist genauso, wie manche Leute anfangen da jetzt,
irgendwelche Streamerinnen krass zu donaten,
so in der Hoffnung, kriege ich da eine Handynummer,
so nach dem, das ist einfach...
Die sind komplett lost, kannst du vergessen.
Über 1000 Euro zusammen mit augenscheinlich...
Easy Money.
Natalie J. verdient daran nach eigener Aussage
zumindest absolut nichts und hat den Verkauf auch nicht erlaubt.
Ob das legal ist?
Ja, hier haben wir es mit verschiedenen Straftaten zu tun.
Erstens Helerei, Datenhelerei
und letztlich natürlich auch noch die Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Laut Solmecke müssen die Verantwortlichen hier im Zweifel
wohl mit strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen rechnen.
Ach nee.
Die Telegram-Kanäle bewerben auch eine zweite Frau, Hanna.
Hierbei handelt es sich nach unseren Recherchen
um eine deutsche Amateur-Porno-Darstellerin.
Dabei ist das doch heute eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht mehr nötig alles.
Es gibt so viele...
Leute, fragt mich nicht, woher ich das weiß.
Und ich frag mich auch, wer...
Egal, ich sag's euch jetzt einfach.
Das ist heute noch eigentlich gar nicht mehr nötig.
Wenn du dir anguckst, wie viele erfolgreiche
V-Tubing-Model-Camgirls, wie auch immer man das nennt,
es überhaupt mittlerweile gibt,
du brauchst gar keine echten Mädels mehr zu zeigen.
Du brauchst einfach nur einen 3D-Model
und jemand mit einer schönen Stimme. Fertig.
Erfolglos kontaktiert haben,
hat sie sich auf unser erstes Video hin bei uns gemeldet.
Konkrete Antworten auf unsere Fragen
bezüglich einer möglichen Beteiligung an der Mache
hat sie uns nicht gegeben.
Sie sagt lediglich, zum anderen Thema kann ich nur sagen,
dass ich über alles informiert bin.
Ob sie letztlich an möglichen Gewinnen aus verkauften Paketen
oder an dem Netzwerk insgesamt beteiligt war,
lässt sich durch diese Aussage nicht konkret feststellen.
Warum genau ist da jetzt
ein Pistolen-Lade-Sound im Hintergrund gewesen?
Aussage nicht konkret feststellen.
Das ist so voll dramatisch gemacht immer, Alter.
Wir vermuten, dass hinter den Instagram-Seiten
und den Telegram-Kanälen letztlich die gleichen Personen stecken.
Beziehungsweise dass die jeweiligen Verantwortlichen
eng zusammenarbeiten.
Erst werden die jungen Insta-Follower in die Gruppen geschleust.
Sie werden mutmaßlich gestohlene Nacktbilder
und pornografische Inhalte unter dem Deckmantel
von Einsendungen geteilt.
Die eine Sache ist hier das mutmaßlich gestohlene Material
der OnlyFans-Darstellerinnen.
Eine ganz andere sind Bilder,
die eventuell einfach von Privatpersonen stammen
und im Internet gelandet sind.
All diese Inhalte werden dann als Kontext genutzt,
um die Follower mit Lisa und Hannah bekannt zu machen
und diese zu bewerben.
Ich mein, so im Kern gibt es diesen Scam
auf die eine oder andere Art schon ewig.
Das endliche Ziel ist es dann,
die Pakete der beiden Frauen zu verkaufen.
Das alles ist in dieser Form, zumindest in Bezug auf Lisa,
einfach ein groß angelegter Scam.
Wir haben auch versucht, mutmaßliche Verantwortliche
hinter dem Netzwerk der Instagram-Seiten zu kontaktieren
und die GmbH in Bayern um Stellungnahme gebeten.
Wir haben keine Antwort.
Nein, das wäre das gedacht.
Das Ganze wird einige von euch sicherlich an die Masche
von Dein Beichtstuhl aus dem Jahr 2018 erinnern.
Falls ihr das nicht mitbekommen habt,
das entsprechende Exposed von uns haben wir euch verlinkt.
Ich sag doch, diese Masche ist das...
Der Scam ist an sich ja schon alt.
Telegram hier ein strukturelles Problem.
Wie weit verbreitet sind diese Maschen?
Der Telegram-Kanal Blacklist warnt alleine im deutschsprachigen Raum
vor zahlreichen ähnlichen Catfishing-Scams.
Aber die Leute sind teilweise...
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht korrekt.
Ich will das nicht schönreden und sagen,
das kann man doch machen, das ist doch alles toll.
Das haben sie im Video auch genug gesagt,
dass das auch illegal ist.
Aber die Leute sind teilweise auch einfach so unglaublich dumm,
dass sie auf so was reinfallen.
Das ist unfassbar, unfassbar.
Ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen.
Scheuer sein kann.
Das ist so pepega einfach nur.
Telegram hat nicht auf unsere Bitte um Stellungnahme reagiert.
Unabhängig davon ist es recht überraschend,
wie lange so etwas bei Instagram durchgehen kann.
Die Links zu den...
Juckt das doch alles nicht, solange das Leute und Views Leute
auf die Seite bringen, ist das Instagram vollkommen egal.
Instagram interessiert das erst,
wenn das geschäftsschädigende Ausmaße annimmt.
Dann ist das Instagram nicht die Bohne.
Wir haben jedenfalls alle intervierten Accounts gemeldet
und Instagram kontaktiert.
Hier ihre Stellungnahme.
Missbräuchliches Verhalten wie Spam oder Betrug
sind auf unserer Plattform nicht erlaubt.
Wir entfernen diese Inhalte, sobald wir davon erfahren.
Und siehe da, nach unserem Kontakt
sind 19 der 21 Seiten gelöscht worden.
Nur blau gesoffen und Horror-Workstories
und noch online mit zusammengerechnet knapp 340.000 Followern.
Dieses Netzwerk aus Instapages, diese Telegram-Gruppen,
sie wirken wie eine vergorene Kombination des Schlechtesten,
was beide Apps zu bieten haben.
Für die Only-Fans-Darstellerinnen
mag es hier nur um den Klau von Material gehen.
Aber wie viele der gezeigten Frauen in den Kanälen
sind vielleicht einfach Privatpersonen?
Wir fragen uns, ob diese Masche wirklich das Beste ist,
was man mit Millionen von Followern auf die Beine stellt.
Nö, aber es bringt Geld.
Mindestens eine der Instagram-Pages hat in der Vergangenheit
augenscheinlich auch eine schnelle Methode,
Geld zu verdienen, beworben.
Nutzt man die Reichweite vielleicht einfach für immer neue Maschen?
Ach nee.
Ja, wir wissen doch alle, warum die das machen.
...toten so viel Reichweite zu monetarisieren.
Vielleicht wird es einfach mal Zeit für einen Karrierewechsel.
Cheers.
Wieder ultra dramatisch gemacht, das Video, ey.
Okay, was kannst du? 39 Sekunden, Full-Stack-Developer.
Jawoll.
Okay.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, als klar.
Okay, okay.
Mhm, mhm, mhm.
Okay, als klar.
So ist es.
Ah, yes.
Alles klar, gut.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen.
Building is stealthy, PlayStation 5.
Okay.
Zeig mal her.
Hunger is fuck.
Das Ding sieht aus, hat jemand...
Ja, was heißt, hat jemand wahrscheinlich...
Habt ihr WALL-E geguckt?
Das sieht aus wie Eva oder Eve aus WALL-E.
Guckt euch die Eva aus WALL-E an, guckt euch die PlayStation 5 an.
Es fehlen bloß noch blaue Punkte oben.
Okay, wann, wann wird das Gehäuse gebaut?
Die meisten Leute haben eher das Problem,
die bekommen gar keine PS5,
die, die kommen gar nicht in die Versuchung,
sich ein eigenes Gehäuse zu bauen.
Die meisten Leute haben eher das Problem,
die bekommen gar keine PS5,
die, die kommen gar nicht in die Versuchung,
sich ein eigenes Gehäuse zu bauen.
Ja.
Mein, das ist das Power Supply?
Was ist das?
Man hört immer wieder ein Teams- oder Discord-Sound.
Was ist das denn hier?
Dein Burger steckt oben unten.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der Chat sich jibaden lässt,
oder ob der Chat mich jibaded,
in dem Sie nicht verstehen, dass ich jibade.
Das ist ja total geil.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der Chat mich jibaded,
in dem Sie nicht verstehen, dass ich jibade.
dass ich jebaite. Das kann reverse, das könnte auch ein reverse jebait im chat sein.
also ich bin noch nie da in die verlegenheit gekommen
hier karbon zeug drehmeln schneiden zu müssen
ähnlich gefällig wie asbestar staub sagt der chat, ist das so?
na dann ist doch unbedingt was was man mal bauen muss
was ist das? ist das der an- und ausschaltknopf oder?
ach led, ein grill?
du kannst aber davon ausgehen, dass die playstation 5 so gebaut ist, dass es funktioniert.
und jetzt hat er unten überall so komische dinger raus stehen.
was habe ich da für ein komisches emote in mein board?
das kannst du mit jeder säge machen, ich glaube nicht, dass du deine speziell japanische säge benutzen musst.
das ist keine japanische säge.
naja so geil sieht das jetzt nett aus, das kann man schöner machen.
was ist das denn gerade?
To gouge off a significant amount of wood making it smooth with a lot of sanding
Because of the mitre joints here the wood grain flows around these curves and looks even better
After adding some natural beeswax and buffing it to a shine as it enriches the grain of the wood and gives it a much deeper
tonality
In Comparison to what you see, I don't build any PS5 cases
Gehäuse
Aber wenn ich eins bauen würde dann würde ich es ordentlicher machen
Wollt gerade sagen wie funktioniert das mit der kühlung
Ich habe keine japanische säge ich kann das gar nicht machen
Das wird aber ganz schön schnell staubig da drinnen
Naja
Weiß nicht irgendwie finde ich nicht dass es gut aussieht
Was ist das wackelig das ist wackelig
Naja also für selbstgemacht ist es schon okay aber es wird so schön finde ich das jetzt nicht
Das sieht oben tatsächlich ganz cool aus
So wirklich geil finde ich das nicht sieht aus wie alles alles radio oder so
Ich weiß nicht
Also ich würde ehrlich gesagt das normale playstation 5 Gehäuse bevorzugen
Ja das stimmt
Wenn er eine Stealth PS5 bauen will wäre das nicht am besten das ding einfach irgendwo dahinter zu
mounten ohne gehäuse drumherum und nur die kabel für das display rauszuführen dann wäre es komplett Stealth
Oder alternativ man könnte auch einfach die ps5 hinter den schrank stellen fertig
Dann ist er auch weg dann ist auch gestalt
Am ende habe ich doch kein nass selbst gebaut
Na dann wenn er kein nass selbst baut dann ist alles in ordnung derauer
Also leute ich habe übelst hunger wollen wir noch das bauer video gucken ist ja grad ist ja grad relativ neu realmax
Dankeschön für den für den sub
Kommen wir gucken was haben herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren video ich habe euch schon vor einigen
Wochen auch schon einigen monaten ich glaube mittlerweile sogar schon vor einem jahr mal gesagt dass ich mein
eigenes nass bauen wollte ich bin zeitlich dazu nie gekommen dann habe ich mich irgendwann entschlossen
einfach nass zu kaufen ja dann habe ich euch immer mal gefragt schon für elektronik angestellt sieben
monat ist ab stadt hdds für nass weil es aus meiner sicht einfach sinnvoller war für die anwendung die
ich habe weil es ist mittlerweile erschwinglicher geworden sind durch hier hat sich das zwar jetzt
wieder ein bisschen geändert aber tendenziell ist es so dass hdds ja von der laufzeit her einfach nur
von der dauer wie sie laufen begrenzt sind und ssd ist von der schreibleistung ich habe jetzt bei dem
was ich mit meinem nass machen möchte nicht so krass was nass leistung und deswegen sollte ein
nass mit ssd ist bei mir deutlich länger halten und es sollte voraussehbarer sein wann eine ssd
ausfällt in der zwischenzeit habe ich mich post bekommen von stenology das habe ich euch ja schon
mal gesagt dass die sich bei mir gemeldet haben und die haben gesagt wir wollen dir geld geben
für uns ein ds 16 21 xs plus sind das die 10g schau mal in discord ja mach ich nach wenn ich
bin ich hier fertig sind das die 10g varianten plus es plus sehr sehr gespannt was dieses
ding können wird oder die katz schicken wird sich beschwert schon wieder ja das steht in der
kiste oder kann ich rein habe ich mir dazu noch micro ssd gekauft die habe ich mir glücklicherweise
schon vor diesem ganzen schia drama bestellt also das sind micron 5300 pro sata ssd 4 terabyte knapp
pro ssd haben 8400 terabyte tbw also extrem hohe schreibleistung dementsprechend gehe ich davon
aus dass die mich mindestens fünf jahre begleiten werden ich habe die gekauft ungefähr 450 euro
das stück vor circa zwei monaten mittlerweile kosten die glaube ich 650 euro also habe ich noch
zum richtigen zeitpunkt gekauft sehr sehr gespannt jetzt mal alles aus und dann geht's weiter dieses
video präsentiert von der neuen corset der kram ist halt teuer geworden also überall ich meine
mittlerweile kannst du dir ja nichts mehr kaufen schia mining macht ssd ist teuer und festplatten
teuer kryptowährungen stells mining macht grafikkarten teuer ist aber cpus und mainboards
sind noch das einzige billige oder was heißt billig by the way diese tastatur die hatte ich
die hatte ich die die korsa rgb die die k95 hat richtig gesagt er bietet ein robust die ghosting
starte doppelte doppelte tasten anschläge und alles richtiger müll hat mir nicht gefallen plus
packt bis zu sechs hdd ssd wie auch immer kann noch m2 ja ok weiter im text wie so ein
ding innen drin aufgebaut ist ok da haben wir erst mal alles kabels usb es ist doch kein 10g
oder oder ist es 10g kupfer würde mich jetzt wundern tatsächlich doch hier guck mal 10g
ist 10g ok aber 10g kupfer port
netz toll lüfter machen wir das ding mal auf schauen wir uns das mal genauer
also unten drunter ist erstmal so eine klappe ja gut das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich spannend
das ist halt ein zynologie gerät schon demontiert habe was macht er da warum braucht er das auch
die typische tüpfelchen aber ansonsten sieht es schon mal sehr gut aus hier unter diesem kleinkühler
ich jetzt gerade entfernt habe ich lesen kann wegen licht ein bisschen schwierig das sehende ok dann
sollte das auch mega angenehm sein magst du keinen 10 gr und 45 doch kann man kann man machen
hier bei mir einfach im arbeitsraum in der regel ist halt auch sowohl das equipment als auch die
die netzwerkarten und kabels und kabel nicht unbedingt aber ist mit sfp plus und direkt
attach halt billiger ok das video ist langweilig er macht er macht werbung für sein oder jenas was
witzig ist was insofern witzig ist dass er in einem werbevideo für sein oder jenas noch mal
werbung für kosa kosa macht der hat wirklich dass das youtube sellout game durchgespielt da kann ich
mir scheibe von abschneiden so muss es machen soll youtube letzte chance ein gutes video
vorzuschlagen sonst gehe ich was essen gucken dass ich keine subs übersehen ab
fantomate zwei minuten vor zwei minuten vor zwei minuten für den primes ab
das ist langweilig ist das original is the egg fliegt whatsapp raus ist mir auch egal ich benutze
kein whatsapp ich bin glaube ich der einzige auf der welt der noch nie einen whatsapp account hatte
richtig boomer style ich weiß ich hatte noch nie in den whatsapp account
ok die machen kann ziemlich viel werbung sein oder jubis aussieht
facebook facebook habe ich ja auch nur erstellt weil ich damals die videos posten wollte auf
facebook also die ankündigung dazu hast du dir mal oracle cloud freetier angesehen nein noch nie
ohje achtung ab wann warum kriege ich diesen mist überall empfohlen
ach jetzt habe ich gelesen also frage im chat war was empfiehlst du im privaten
bereich für ein nass außer selbst moment außer selbstbau via pie hauptanwendung
plextreaming also raspberry pie finde ich nicht gut als nass weil die haben ein nachteil die
haben bisschen geld gespart beim raspberry pie und du hast keinerlei encryption in der cpu das
heißt sobald du deine festplatten irgendwie verschlüsseln willst ist mega langsam und auch
sonst ist ein raspberry pie fürs nass jetzt nicht so das allerbeste kann man aber machen kann man
machen ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so mies ansonsten kannst du dir wahrscheinlich ein
x-beliebiges zynology oder wie heißen die anderen qnap oder sonst was nass kaufen da
machst du mich allzu viel verkehrt ich muss dir aber ehrlich sagen ich kenne mich in dem
bereich nicht sonderlich gut aus ok leute ich gehe jetzt essen ich habe hunger
hast du schon mal was cooles mit grafana unter einer heizung gemacht nee noch nie alles klar
leute wir sehen uns macht's gut vielleicht vielleicht bin ich heute abend noch mal
mit wenn du aus package manager also wir sehen uns bis denn zu gucken ist da frazier da kann
ich in hausten nope alles klar bis denn